morning
everybody Welcome to environment and
agriculture this morning and I'd like to
start our
meeting uh with the Pledge of Allegiance
led by representative
kraton of alance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all thank you thank you all for being
here and braving the elements in order
to uh come and hear
us I'm just getting the pink cards put
together here for uh for our
hearings and um I want to uh as per
representative B bixby's request
uh we have three bills this morning
dealing with Organic uh certification
organic food
certification um if you have some
comments to make in general about
organic farming Organic
certification you could you are invited
to make those
comments um in the test testimony for
our hearing for HB
1184 but we we would like to uh limit
the
discussion um
on specific parts of these
bills um so if you have specific
information regarding testimony for an
individual bill please make those at the
appropriate time when that bill is being
heard we are going to start off this
morning with HB
1184 which is relative to making an
appropriation to The Organic
certification program I'm going to uh
open this meeting inviting the sponsor
of this bill representative Bixby to
please introduce the bill good
morning good morning thank you madam
chair for the record representative
Peter Bixby representing Dober uh and um
also a member of this committee uh
and uh so uh what I'm presenting here is
uh relative to making appropriation uh
to The Organic certification program and
the real purpose of HB 1184 is to
strengthen the Organic certification in
the Department of Agriculture markets
and food before I get into the details
of the bill I want to present some
background on Organic certification
there's more to organic than food you
pay more for so you don't so you know it
won't have nasty
chemicals uh in the mid
early to mid 20th century Agricultural
Science split into two branches the
dominant Branch with heavy investment
from industry and a lot of work from
land grant universities focused on
chemicals that help plants grow how
could farmers use soluble chemically
active forms of nutrients like nitrogen
phosphorus and potassium to get plants
to grow
faster what chemicals when sprayed on
Plants would reduce Pest and disease
pressure what herbicides would kill
competing weeds it turned out that the
nitrogen reduction process developed in
World War I for making bombs could also
produce fertilizer and nerve toxins used
for chemical warfare also killed insect
pests the other branch which garnered
very little corporate interest
considered bi considered biologically
active soil to be key to good plant
growth if you feed the soil the soil
will provide the right nutrients uh the
right amounts of available nitrogen
potassium and phosphorus to the plants
Central to this soil-based approach was
adding a lot of compost to the soil
because compost is rich in decaying
organic matter this approach to
agriculture became called organic in
English it's called um biological in
other
languages uh organic plant scientists
were concerned that since that synthetic
pesticides and fungicides would harm
soil health so they limited pesticide
and fungicide use to biologically Source
materials organic agriculture went from
being a very tiny Niche to a somewhat
less tiny niche in the 19660 s When
Rachel Carson's work exposed the
downsides of DD DDT and other synthetic
pesticides in the 1970s and and 1980s
the organic organic food became more
popular and enough more profitable
profitable that producers feared that
unscrupulous sellers would claim food
was organically grown when it was
not a number of private mostly nonprofit
or organic farming organizations started
certification programs to verify organic
practices in our region the main farmers
and gardeners Association or mfka and
the various State branches of the
Northeast organic Farmers Association or
NOA filled this
role the Myriad different certifiers did
not agree on the standards for organic
production and some felt others were too
laxs Congress saw different St standards
as creating the potential for fraud and
passed a bill that placed the USDA in
charge of creating a national organic
program the national the NOP created
standards for organic uh for organic
agricultural practices and allowable
materials the standards would be
overseen by accredit accredited
certifying agencies or acas an ACA could
not also be an advising or ad ad
advocacy
organization in some
states the Department of Agriculture set
up an an ACA program many of the private
certifiers were part of organizations
that did advising and advoc advocacy a
lot of these spun-off separate
corporations to become acas including
mafka NOA Vermont NOA Mas
Etc it should be not noted that the NOP
made no requirement that farmers get
certified by a specific ACA in their
region any ACA willing to work with a
farm would count as long as an ACA
certifies a farm it can Market its
products as USD or USDA organic without
ACA certification no claims of organic
can be made NOA New Hampshire found the
challenge of setting up an ACA to be
substantial so the department of
agricult Department of Agriculture
markets and food under former
commissioner Steve Taylor offered to
take on that role and helped develop
legislation that to make that possible
the work of certification would be done
under the division of regulatory
services using division
Personnel the department has been
working with New Hampshire organic
farmers who chose who choose to use
their services for more than two decades
ades just as a reminder even though many
people use organic as a proxy for a free
of synthetic chemicals the term really
means farming
practices are aimed at creating healthy
soils to create healthy
plants another aspect of certification
we need to touch on is Scopes organic
standards are divided into four branches
or Scopes crops crops and produce animal
agriculture processing and handling and
wildcrafting the US USDA approves acas
separately for each scope and each scope
has different requirements so not all
CER certifiers cover all four Scopes
until 2021 the Department of Agriculture
markets and Foods did all four Scopes in
the summer of 2021 the former director
of regulatory Services left on fairly
short notice for family reasons on the
way out she informed the commissioner
that the Department's compliance with
the animal Agriculture and processing
and handling Scopes was having serious
problems
the department tried to find a remedy
but determined that there was a serious
risk that the national organic program
would remove their certification unless
a number of Fairly costly steps were
taken the department informed farmers
and businesses
using animal and animal and processing
handling Scopes that they would need to
find alternative certifiers for the
following year this created a great deal
of unhappiness and I think there might
be some people testifying after me who
might mention that a Senate bill was fi
filed in an attempt to fix the problem
but it did not pass the department
scaled back doing only the crop and
produce scope which does include maple
syrup when the commission when the
commissioner received the most recent
audit from USDA NOP in early 2023 he
realized that some improvements needed
to be made to the structure of the
certification program to make it
sustainable he reached out to TOA New
Hampshire to help figure out a plan of
action NOA New Hampshire surveyed their
farmer members and held listening
sessions to get a sense of what New
Hampshire Farmers would prefer there was
strong support among the respondents for
uh damp to consider continue
certification even if it would require
higher fees in the future because of
that support I offered to file this bill
what the bill does is it creates one and
a half specific organ specific Organic
certification positions in the
department which is which is one change
encouraged by the national Grant or
organic
program the bill also makes an
appropriation for them for the second
year of this bium that appropriation
will be partially off offset by fees I'm
happy to take questions but I will defer
most questions about finances workload
and noop requirement to the commissioner
I believe that there are members of the
organic farming committee here who would
also who will also be providing input
thank you thank you representative Bixby
does the committee members any committee
members have questions
regarding
um this
testimony representative Duty good
morning good morning thank you thank you
for taking my question um I so we have
an another bill coming forward I believe
this morning that involves the
USDA it m if if we passed this bill so
is this actually a standalone bill and
the one and a half position would uh be
um an assist to organic farmers or is
there a whole package that we need to be
considering so the the three bills we're
hearing this morning are all completely
separate bills uh so they all they all
stand on their own merits um
and uh this bill is specifically about
providing the resources to the
department to be able to uh continue to
do the organic uh program and this is
this bill is really about
resources thank
you so my question is um do we already
have this program
funded uh I can the the commissioner can
talk about that in more detail but uh
the program was not funded as a separate
entity uh and still is not funded as a
separate entity it is uh under the
department of regulatory services and it
uses uh regulatory Services Personnel uh
and and the way that those Personnel are
funded uh is something that the uh
commissioner can speak to more clearly
than I can thank you any other questions
for representative
Bixby seeing none thank you and let's
move on and I call up uh Joyce
Ford who has requested three minutes to
speak good morning Miss
Ford I'm a little nervous this is my
first time ever testifying so well we
don't bite it's okay and if you have
testimony be welling it would be uh nice
to pass it around
yeah thank you for bringing that by the
way Madame chair members of the
committee thank you my name is Joyce
Ford I'm from Hillsboro New Hampshire I
have been involved in Organic
certification since the 1980s and I
currently serve as accreditation
committee chair for an international
organization that accredits Organic
certification bodies
globally Organic certification is
required if an operation uses the term
organic in any of its Marketing in 2023
the USDA has imposed new rules on
accredited certifying agents I will
refer to them as acas to kind of shorten
it up as part of their strengthening
organic enforcement rules which are
implemented by March 19th
2024 so in addition to requiring more
types of operations in the supply chain
to be certified all inspectors and
certifier reviewers have specific
qualification and training requirements
new ones and this Rule now requires
certifying agents to conduct uh 5% of
their operations as unannounced
inspections complete mass balance
balance audits during the annual on-site
inspections and verify traceability back
to the previous certified operation in
the supply chain during
inspections I know this is pretty
technical but I just want you to know
that this is a very technical program
that that needs people who are very
trained to do this kind of work so in
order to remain accredited the New
Hampshire Department of Agriculture
markets and Foods Organic certification
program needs funding to adequately
train their personnel to comply with
these new rules schols they will need an
adequate number of staff to review
applications perform the on-site
inspections and provide final reviews of
all certification documents for
operations before making the
certification decision and all of these
steps require a quality management
system that tracks these
activities one additional point I would
like to make most accredited organic
certifying agents base their sliding
scale fee structure which is public
information on their website
on Gross organic sales this allows
smaller organic farmers to get certified
without undue financial hardship the New
Hampshire Department of Agriculture
markets and food currently bases their
fee structure on acreage or Greenhouse
square footage neither of which is a
marker of the size income a farmer can
actually make on that amount of land the
department says it doesn't collect gross
organic sales information in the
application but it could um then they
also could then use a sliding scale fee
structure to keep organic the smaller
organic farm certified so I support
House Bill 1184 FNA which increases
funding for the New Hampshire Department
of aegs markets and food Organic
certification program to allow the
department to maintain their
accreditation status with the USDA for
the crop scope thank you thank you so
much for your
testimony and are there any
questions
um
for Miss
Ford yeah no questions so thank
you um I call Mr David
Trumble good morning Mr
Trumble where are you from Mr Trumble um
I'm from the town of wear thank you my
name is David Trumble I'm a certified
organic farmer I have been certified
organic since 1987 the first year that
we had Organic certification in the
state I want to talk about three things
first is a little history of the program
and second is just a couple brief
comments about organic and then a few
comments about the bill itself in the
mid 80s NOA worked with the state
legislature to create the statute that
set up Organic certification in the
first two years NOA did the
certification I was on the board of NOA
at that time the Department of
Agriculture came to one of our board
meetings and said what would you think
if we took over the program and NOA said
yes the Department of Agriculture said
we can build this program we have the
resources NOA didn't have those
resources so there was a commitment made
to grow the program and it did grow to
almost 200 farms uh not that many years
ago that history is important because it
shows that the Department of Agriculture
made a commitment and that commitment is
what grew the program in the state those
resources were essential over the last
38 years the organic farmers in the
state have worked with the Department of
Agriculture cooperatively in a lot of
ways the department set up an organic
advisory committee uh they provided
trainings to other Farmers that were put
on by the department but the trainings
were done by the organic farmers and the
commissioner tur or organic farms to see
their production techniques and and
personally I was involved in all three
of those uh different aspects that
history is important because it shows
that there's been a longstanding mutual
respect between the organic farming
community and the Department of
Agriculture and also I think it aligns
with the Department's duties described
in the statute that's
4252 which says that the department
shall be responsible for promoting and
regulating agriculture in all its
branches uh whether you conceive of
organic farming as a separate branch of
New Hampshire's agriculture or whether
or not we are populated in all the
branches but in any event we're there
we're in every branch of Agriculture and
it makes sense that the department does
the regulating for our program I don't
have data I don't think there is any
data but my back of the envelope
estimate is that we collectively sell
millions if not10 million dollars worth
of agricultural products every year we
help support a good thousand workers
directly and indirectly and we obviously
Farm tens of thousands of Acres my
concern I support this bill 100% I have
been a member of the certification
through the department of a I like the
department of a certifiers they do a
thorough exceptionally professional job
I think this bill is a good step in the
right direction my concern is the way
it's worded it sounds as though by 2026
the fees will have to support the entire
program those fees that we have been
able to see are not reasonable they
estimate based on what it's like now my
farm a relatively small farm would cost
$4,900 a year to certify right now I pay
$350 a year to certify in Vermont my
farm would cost a little less than 900
to certify if I did it through Maine it
would be $1,400 there's no way I can
justify almost $5,000 in certification
fees when I could get it done for about
one4 of the cost with another agency if
you adopt this bill but don't adequately
fund it to keep the fees affordable no
organic farmers are going to sign up for
it and eventually the program will die I
know that there's the argument that the
prices haven't gone up in time but even
if you took 350 50 for my farm as the
starting point 38 years ago do a Google
inflation calculator the price would be
$940 so yes fees should go up they
should have been set to inflation to go
up every year but going up to the amount
that it would be what it costs to
support the program these these fees are
too much it's going to lead to the end
of the program so I support this program
I hope that we can continue to work with
the Department of Agriculture and I hope
that you will support the funding so
that the fees would be set comparable to
what it costs in Vermont or Maine in
other words if you don't want the
farmers to flee the program make what
the farmers pay comparable to what they
can get it from another certifier and
have the state pay the balance and I
think that would be about 1/4 of the the
numbers that you have uh from the
commissioner thank you thank you I have
a question and and then uh
representative
ktoa so are you your farm is your farm
certified through the new
Hampshire um certification process I've
been certified with the Department of
Agriculture for the last 36 years the
two before that NOA had the program but
yes how much how much does it cost you
to do that in three $350 is what I pay
$350 okay um and but there are other
organizations that will
certify uh an organic farm yes in Maine
it's called mafka it's the organic
farmers their price system as was
mentioned is set up by gross sales so
for between I'm sorry I have the numbers
right here
uh in Maine a farm that's 60,000 to
100,000 so just a relatively small farm
is
$1,400 anywhere between 100 and2 200,000
it only goes up to
$1,600 so that's affordable in Vermont
they have like a formula but a $70,000
farm would be
$870 a $100,000 farm would be
$1,013 and $150,000 farm would be ,25 so
it's affordable for the farmers at those
rates the the if you make the farmers in
New Hampshire pay for this program in
its entirety the rates will be so high
no very few will do it and once if half
of the farmers leave then scope and
scale you're still going to have these
inspectors that the price is going to go
up even more eventually the program will
collapse so if if we want a program
that's run by the government we have to
find fees that are affordable for the
farmers with which is going to require
some State
subsid um representative kto you have a
question uh thank thank you uh Madam
chair and thank you for coming here
today in this weather and uh taking my
question and my question is basically uh
probably a reiteration of what
representative Aaron talked but I just
want to make sure that I understand
you can get certifi your Organic
certification through mofa or the
Vermont program is that correct you you
can when the uh State eliminated the
dairy and the bread and the processors
program those Farms continued to be
organic and they had to go find
certifiers from out of the state and I
forget who testified but said that the
federal governments does not require
that you that you be certified by the
the certifier within your state so you
can go to another certifier I I believe
the statistics I've seen we have 66
Organic Farms left in New Hampshire and
there's about 50 Organic Farms that are
certified by someone else right
now representative K followup thank you
uh Madam chair So based on what you just
said uh the dairy farms had to find
someone else to certify them and what
did you say that number was that are
currently being certified by the
department of agriculture I believe
there's 66 right now last year and
there's another 50 that are certified
organic farms but not certified I'm
sorry thank you for the question I
didn't uh and there's another 50 that
are not certified by nhda by by some
other certifier and the this when we
when this news came out we a few farmers
and one of them who started the petition
is going to speak started a petition
because we want to support this program
and like without really a great deal of
effort a thousand people supported the
petition to keep the program alive in
New Hampshire and so in the discussions
that have happened between the farmers
and NOA and some with the Department of
Agriculture if this program doesn't
survive NOA has considered the
possibility of setting up a satellite
program where they would basically
become kind of like a link for New
Hampshire Farmers to get certified by
another another certification agency and
that would be a decent backup program
but I feel like it the state support for
this program is important because
organic farmers are an important part of
New Hampshire's agriculture so I I would
prefer to see the
government you know pay what's necessary
so that we keep the program strong and
and I was looking at other professionals
electricians pay $180 a year to get
their license renewed each year master
plumbers pay 300 every two years so
that's about what I'm paying if you made
plumbers and electricians all of a
sudden pay $4,000 a year to get
certified to get their license renewed
you'd have a room full of angry plumbers
and electricians so we're just saying
help keep this program
alive thank you representative kraton
you had a question I'm sorry thank you
so much for your testimony I'm diving
into something that you've been doing
for 37 years so so bear with me here so
this bill right here
1184 it is authorizing from the state
$220,000 to pay for one one and a half
people that's it right that's all this
bill does well there's another provision
in the bill I'm sorry thank you for the
please I'm just reading what I'm reading
here yep there's something um down in
the methodology section on on the page
where it talks about how uh let's
see making the they want to make the
program self- sustaining and fiscal year
2026 and each year thereafter so that's
and I look at the chart with the funds
the expenditure is still 220 every year
for 25 26 27 but the appropriation is
220 220,000 in year 2025 but then it's
zero after that so I I I think there's a
the way if it goes the way it's worded
here for one year you subsidize the
program after that the farmers pay the
whole cost so I I'm just saying I hope
that you'll keep that appropriation
going on going forward
okay and so for follow pleas should
follow
up okay so today you're paying roughly
300 where does the 4,000 come in where
am I reading that in this bill it's not
here um during all these discussions
like I said we've had like a half a
dozen meetings to get ready for this we
were told that the the fee range would
go from a low of 2900 to a high of
4,900 so for my operation I have a few
Acres of vegetables and four green
houses which is 6,000 ft which under the
formula would put me at the high end I'd
be my farm would be almost $5,000 to
certify and I'm sorry go and that's in
26 27 when it goes to zero that would be
cor is that that's your that's your
connection that's my understanding State
takes away the money and then you have
to absorb that 2200 divided by 116
different Farms right so I would say one
way to do that is either to say the
state will make the farmer fees equal to
what Vermont and Maine pay or the state
could adopt a sliding scale like Maine
has Maine just says if your farm grosses
this much and it breaks it down into
income brackets you pay this much so
that way the system that we have for the
right now the acreage plus the green
houses was started decades ago in fact
that was part of being on the advisory
organic committee Vicky Smith asked me
and a couple other Farmers to help her
come up with a fee structure so we we
looked at green houses and said well if
you got this many square feet you're
probably but making this much money so
we we actually came up with these
numbers and they made sense when it was
a total of $300 for the year but now
when it's being asked to cover the
entire cost it doesn't make sense
there's no way a farm like mine could
pay a $5,000 fee so the the the basis of
the of the system acreage or square
footage should be changed to gross
income on the farm okay I'm sorry one so
one last one last I'm
I'm so under the current system
if it's 300
bucks why are we changing that if the
new system is going to cost 4,000 bucks
we're changing that because the cost to
the Department of Agriculture is
exceeding the amount of money they're
bringing in in fees the fees are too low
right now they were never adjusted for
inflation so they should have gone up so
they'd be getting more fee money but
even with that they're saying that the
the cost of running the program would
exceed even an inflationary increase so
in order to keep the program alive they
want the program to either be funded by
you in its entirety or the Farmers fund
it I'm saying we can't afford to fund it
so we need you to to chip in and make it
affordable okay thank you so much
appreciate it thank representative
Murray thank you madam chair um that was
just more along and thank you for taking
my question it was more along the same
lines I was just wanting to make sure
that I understood that you were talking
about the square footage model and
you're making the assumption that under
rules that's the way they're going to
continue
to uh account for the fees I I don't
know that it's been decided yet okay but
I was just saying I would Advocate a a
gross income model it's it's more
Equitable and it would encourage young
Farmers I mean the the key thing is we
don't want to discourage young farmers
who are getting into farming who look at
this and say the the the floor is too
expensive there's no way I'll never even
join the New Hampshire program we have
to make it so that they come in and as
their Farm expands their their income
will go up their certification costs go
up but if the floor is too high no young
farmer will ever even join the program
thank you thank you any other
questions thank you very much for your
testimony this morning appreciate it
you're welcome uh next I would like to
call Nikki
colb and you've requested four and a
half minutes to
speak if something has already been said
um we would appreciate you not repeating
it thank you I'm G to do my best thank
you
all
right I have a copy of my testimony to
share this
one okay all
right thank you for having me here I
should start that I'm the operations
director at no New Hampshire and I'm
representing NOA New
Hampshire I'm going to read my testimony
which I'm going to modify a bit from
just speaking with representive
Bixby the Northeast organic farming
Association of New Hampshire NOA New
Hampshire has been representing organic
farmers gardeners and eaters in New
Hampshire for over 50 years in that time
the organization and its supporters have
seen firsthand the vast development and
Adoption of the organic
movement in 2021 the US organic food
sector generated $ 52 billion doubling
its revenue from just a decade
prior over the same period us Organic
Crop land increased
79% Farmers eaters and researchers agree
organic agriculture benefits human and
planetary Health by growing healthy
foods increasing soil Health preventing
water contamination decreasing exposure
to toxic chemicals and helping mitigate
climate change organic agriculture has
also been proven to boost Farm
resiliency in the face of increasing
extreme weather events including drought
and flooding while improving water
quality as a core partner in the usda's
transition to organic partnership
program called top aimed at increasing
organic acreage across the country NOA
New Hampshire has witnessed the
increasing demand for Organic
certification Services a key component
of the top program is mentorship over
the last 6 months NOA New Hampshire has
matched 15 farmers and food hubs
interested in in transitioning to
organic with Organic farmer mentors all
in just the first year of this program
that means 15 new Farms will be eligible
to become certified organic soon it also
indicates that New Hampshire Farmers
interest in transitioning to organic is
keeping Pace with national Trends
providing New Hampshire with an
opportunity to actively grow our organic
agriculture Community which benefits all
Farmers consumers and our
state the New Hampshire Department of
Agriculture markets and food has been
supporting this growing sector of the
agricultural economy in New Hampshire by
serving as an accredited certifying
agency and ACA for many years and this
program helps organic farmers by be
successful by providing verification for
consumers that their agricultural
products meet USDA organic standards
results from a New Hampshire damp and
NOA New Hampshire survey as well as
numerous stakeholder meetings
consistently indicate that organic
farmers want damp to continue as an
organic certifier why
New Hampshire's organic farmers who
utilize this service view it as the
number one way that New Hampshire damp
supports their operations and supports
them as Farmers working with New
Hampshire damp as an organic certifier
provides New Hampshire's vital Organic
Farms with a direct connection to our
state's Department of Agriculture
Farmers currently certified by the
department deeply value this connection
damp certification damp certification
also provides Farmers with a unified
local organic brand that signifies to
both farmers and consumers that New
Hampshire values and invests in its
Organic
Farms The Organic certification program
has been an investment in our state's
organic farming Community certification
fees have remained static for so long
that the program is no longer
competitive with other certifying
agencies this is not the fault of the
farmers we understand that the fees
would need to increase
um however I understand from speaking
with representative Bixby that the fees
are actually not what this bill is
trying to advocate for um we are going
to continue to Advocate with the
department for Equitable fees for
Farmers on this program we also
understand um as Dave Trumble was just
saying as well that if the fees increase
significantly um Farmers could likely
switch to other certifying
agencies commissioner Jasper has assured
us that he values the organic farming
community and wants to support organic
farmers and we hear that the department
is underfunded and needs this funding
representative Bixby has developed a
solution with this bill that will will
increase the Staffing required by New
Hampshire damp to continue providing an
Organic certification program and again
we are advocating for um fees that will
be reasonable and accessible for organic
farmers so that this program is not cost
prohibitive
excuse me I'm modifying this in my mind
um New Hampshire's Farmers work
tirelessly to preserve our state's
agricultural landscape and Heritage and
should be adequately supported again
through reasonable certification fees
for Farmers who've depended on and
supported this program Through The Years
or by some other means uh NOA New
Hampshire supports HB 1184 and the
farmers who are calling on New Hampshire
damp to continue supporting them now and
into the future thank you and thank you
for your patience with my
modification question uh representative
um Morris thank you thank you for taking
my question I just wondered if you could
tell me the total number of certified
organic farms in New Hampshire and how
many um on average are yearly getting
certified the total through the
department of a or yes okay through the
department of a there's currently 66
certified organic farms and currently
farmers can only be certified for crops
I'm sorry I to see
you you said 66 in New Hampshire 66
certified by the Department of
Agriculture yes there are more than that
certified by other acas representative
Duty yes uh thank you madam chair thank
you for taking my question um if a
farmer can get certified in Vermont or
uh
Maine is there a downside to that and uh
you know I guess my question is why do
we need one in New Hampshire if there
are other options are there any
downsides to
that my first response to that is that
um Farmers have consistently stated that
they specifically value this program as
a direct connection to the Department of
Agriculture and they feel that it helps
represent them um at the state and it is
a it is the number one way that they
feel supported by the department of a
the organic farmers who currently are
certified they can certify with other um
acas if they want but they choose to
certify with the Department of a because
they value that service
deeply I hope that
helps any other questions from the
committee representative coma thank you
madam chair and thank you uh for taking
my question and being here um my
question is is that the top program has
a $100 million grant for the
transitioning couldn't they use some of
those funds to help these people uh get
certified
organically that's a great question
thank you the top program um is not
supposed to be valuing or putting
emphasis on one ACA over another so it
does not pay for Farmers to become
certified it's focused on mentorship
technical assistance Community Building
Workforce Development but not to pay
Farmers to become certified organic it's
a more of a yeah an educational
program
okay thank you any other questions from
the committee seeing none thank you very
much for coming in today on this snowy
morning and uh I'd like to Now call Jim
Riddle who has requested two minutes to
speak he
want thank you madam chair members of
the committee my name is Jim Riddle
Hillsboro I'm a retired organic farmer I
also worked as an organic inspector for
20 years I served a 5-year term on the
USDA National organic Standards Board I
currently serve on the policy and
education Committee of NOA New Hampshire
but I'm here uh speaking on my own
behalf and I'm here to support uh HB
1184 soil-based organic production of
crops and livestock builds soil Health
sequesters carbon fixes nitrogen in the
soil prevents soil erosion protects
water quality recycles new nutrients and
enhances
biodiversity all while producing safe
healthy abundant and tasty
food The Organic Market is growing you
see organic products
everywhere but more of those products
need to be produced here in the granite
state and the legislature should do all
you can to support and promote organic
production and certification in our
state this isn't an investment in our
agriculture environment and Food
Systems and the farmers here in New
Hampshire need a new hampshire-based
Organic certification program that's
fully funded that's well staffed and
professional to provide certification
services in the granite state yes
farmers can go elsewhere but if there's
a a a strong reliable certifier in the
State I see it as just part of the New
Hampshire Advantage so I hope you can
support this bill make this investment
and uh get the professional staff that
damp needs to continue offering
certification Services thank you thank
you any questions seeing none thank you
very much oh oh oh I'm sorry I didn't
see you representative Haskins thank you
chair um and thank you for Tes in Mr
riddle I wonder if you could help me
understand a little better about the
previous comment made about the
connection to the department as being an
asset of New Hampshire
certification perhaps this is for the
commissioner I'm not sure yeah I
representative thank you for your
question members of the committee
um there's a certain identity that
farmers have uh built in relation to
their certification status and um it's a
New Hampshire logo that they get to
carry in addition to the very familiar
USDA organic seal that um I think many
farmers are quite attached to their
buyers look for um and it it shows that
you know a sense of Pride that the
product was produced and certified here
in the granite state if they're
certified by an outof State entity they
would no longer uh carry that logo that
logo would disappear from the
marketplace uh so I think um that reason
alone is is uh you know has market value
instead of carrying a logo from the
state of Maine or the state of Vermont
or Bay State in
Massachusetts uh so I think that is uh
how I'd answer that question I
appreciate it thank you thank you
representive K thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question um you
mentioned that and may maybe I didn't
hear that you're sit on the board of NOA
New
Hampshire no okay I am on the policy and
education committee I served on the
national organic Standards Board so
maybe that's where the two got follow up
thank you um thank you for that
clarification my question is is no for
Vermont no for M you know mofa um they
all have their certifi organic farmers
in each of their respective States why
does not no for New Hampshire do the
same yeah and uh uh thank you
representative for your question um
that's been uh I I think there was some
background given earlier by a previous
commentator that they did years ago but
the department uh offered to work in
Partnership and provide the Professional
Service and then NOA New Hampshire could
focus on
education uh you know farm field days
events the winter conference and
delivering other services uh to The
Growers in the state with the Department
because they do other types of
certification it seemed like a natural
role for them to
fill thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for
speaking this morning um I'd like to
call Lara mati
good morning and you've requested one
minute to
speak um my name is laa maias I'm here
representing Rosy's Garden the oldest
certified organic farm in the state um
it's vitally important to us to have
this certification program and for it to
continue to be affordable for Farmers
we're lucky that we have been able to be
certified since um the farm was founded
in the80s but not every Farm um has been
so fortunate awareness of eating
organically has grown over the years and
we've observed this firsthand in our own
um consumer base the number of people
who come in looking for specifically
organic products and our own organic
products has dramatically increased the
organic methods we use also benefit the
health of our soil water and help
mitigate the effects of climate change
and water contamination ation in our
community it's vital to our farm and
also our community to continue to be
certified organic and held to the
standards set by the New Hampshire
Department of Agriculture markets and
food we ask that you continue to make
this program affordable and accessible
to Farmers across the state thank you
thank you any questions seeing none
appreciate it like to call now do U
representative Dan Wolf from Newberry
New Hampshire and you've requested two
minutes
thank you madam excuse me Madam chairman
and members of the EG committee um I'm
going to speak a little bit and in
response to some of the questions that
were asked here and I have another bill
following this one um organic gives
consumers a choice it's an important
choice that they have that they
willingly make generally organic is more
expensive but people want to know where
their product is what it contains
Etc and they choose New Hampshire over
others because they know it's a fresher
product and it's locally
grown I have got had to go to the state
of Maine to get my poultry certified my
eggs because New Hampshire did away with
it two years ago and when I went into
spring ledge to deliver my eggs the
first first time and I had a state of
main logo on it the phone started
ringing and people asked what's the
matter you can't get certified in New
Hampshire are they stale eggs what's the
problem so we need to have a connection
to our own state to our own Agriculture
and yes I'm paying more money in Maine
I'm paying
$750 to certify egg production but I was
only paying 300 in New Hampshire and
that 300 has been fixed for the last 20
years I've been a certified producers
since
20 since 2000 so 24 years and this
program has existed since
1987 I'll speak further on uh 168 down
the road but it's important it's vitally
important to keep it going and not send
us packing down the road
thank you any questions representative
dudy uh thank you madam chair thank you
representative why haven't the fees
changed uh was it put in statute and has
to change by Statute or um Can can you
elaborate I I'm pausing because I don't
want
to say things that I shouldn't when it
was put in statue in 198 87 the word was
may have an organic program not shell
and you'll see the next bill that I'm
put it in would have put it in Statue as
a shell
program and when commissioner Steve
Taylor started the program and worked
with NOA to take it off of noa's hands
and have the state behind the
program I think there was a mistake made
and it didn't say shell it say May and
over the
years there has been no fee increase I
can bring you the checks that I wrote
when my daughter was collecting eggs
back in the year 2000 and we're paying
the same amount of money I I may not be
exact on that but it hasn't changed
us any oh represent Murray thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
for taking my question it I just want to
clarify
am I hearing you corre correctly that
you maybe the inference wasn't there but
you seem to have alluded to the fact
that um with your main certification
people are assuming that your product is
from the state of Maine that's one of
the questions that I got asked how come
I had to change did I not pass New
Hampshire certification and had to go
out of state to get
certified I've been selling organic eggs
as I said since the year
And when they see a different logo a
sticker put on the box people
wonder any other
questions thank you thank you madam
chair thank you
representative like to Now call and I'm
sorry I can't read the writing it's Saul
B from kirar Gore
Farm s ow there you okay I'll take that
looks close
enough thank you that's that's
me is that b a u r b o w r I apologize
for my
scribbles and uh I will I did I was
scribbling furiously uh back here in the
chair as well because uh as a uh 7day
week uh certified organic farm I uh this
was my first opportunity to try to
organize my thoughts so please uh bear
with me uh my name is s bow and uh I'm
with kir sge cor farm and my parents
started the farm in 1981 and we've been
certified through the state of New
Hampshire for over 30 years uh if we can
remember to the beginning of the 2023
growing
season this was probably one of the
hardest growing seasons on New Hampshire
Farms that we've seen in the past
several decades now is not the time to
be taking these services that the state
provides away from the
farmers
and it is also not the fault of
certified organic farms in the state
that the fee structure has not been
addressed for the last almost 30 years
to take this program away from these
Farms on a very short
notice I think is disingenuous for what
New Hampshire Farmers deserve and for
what they need to survive uh a little
piece on that is we're very familiar
with working with the state of New
Hampshire we know the faces of the
certifiers I have their phone numbers in
my cell phone right now they're very
responsive if I reach out they get back
they help us to make sure that we go
through the Organic certification
process in a way that gets everybody
what they need and keeps our farm
certified uh and
that it's
another stressor on businesses and Farms
that we do not need right now after this
struggle of a growing season and looking
forward to try to increase our profits
and continue our business going uh in
the years to
come
uh the state in my opinion should be
interested in pursuing programs that
address our mounting societal
issues and farms organic farms are
uniquely positioned to help us in a lot
of these uh issues that we're struggling
with with today the Mental Health crisis
the uh uh environmental crisis um the
opioid epidemic covid-19 pandemic
affordable housing Health Care climate
change early childhood education and
attracting young people to stay and to
move to the state of New Hampshire
organic farms
supply
Supply the ability to help it is not a
solution to all of these crises but it
is it lends a helping hand in all of
these departments would we rather have
people having Mental Health crisis on
conquered main street or in the lettuce
field down on the back 40 where they
have friends and family around them we
organic farms are leading the way in
climate Improvement and contamination
reduction
strategies
um and again with with all of these
things it was the first time the
covid-19 pandemic hit and everything
shut down it was the first time in my
life I was told that I was an essential
business and that people cared and they
wanted me to bring my employees to work
every day to make sure that the state
food supply wasn't in danger if you
remember the shelves at the market
basket and the Hannafords were bare for
a long time and if things had gone a
little bit worse who knows where we
could have been and maybe we would have
had to rely on New Hampshire Farms more
than we did but I glad that we were
there to help those people who needed us
when they
did I think that the state should
actively help and not hinder businesses
who are are already currently on the
Forefront of many of these issues a yes
vote for this bill doesn't just show
support for organic agriculture as a
whole but it shows committed support to
its businesses its land its people and
its future there is no education level
skill set or professional career path
that excludes you from working on and
with New Hampshire certified organic
farms thank you thank you
questions seeing none thank you very
much uh now ask Sarah Hansen to come and
speak three minutes
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee my name is Sarah Hansen and
I've worked in New Hampshire a organic
agriculture for over 10 years as a
farmer a coordinator of a Cooperative
community supported agriculture Farm
share CSA Farm share and as a small
retail business
owner with 10,000 acres in organic crops
and almost 9,000 Acres in pasture in
organic pasture New Hampshire has a
vibrant organic food system that plays
out everywhere from direct Market retail
markets to our state's tourism
website small farms of which we have
many both in terms of typical average
acreage and revenue earned make up a
large part of our state's perceived
rural
character providing funding for The
Organic certification program ensures
that Farms who provide the backdrop of
Agriculture for our state are receiving
the funding and representation they
require over the past decade of working
on a small farm the strongest connection
I have made with our state government
has been participating in our Organic
certification program there was a
question asked earlier about um the
difference between anopa certification
and the state certification and one of
the biggest differences that I see
and sow just alluded to this was that
the state provides certification right
now they do not provide and they're not
allowed to as a certifier provide
education or Community connections
between Farms if I go and I'm getting
certified and I say oh how do other
Farms do this my certifier is not
allowed to answer that question um
that's a really big service that NOA has
separately been responsible for
providing so I see the two entities
working in unison um I see the state the
organic certifier that comes to our farm
every year as my direct connection to
this state house and the values that I
hold as an organic farmer are
represented in in the state by the
department holding that certification
for
us
um our Farmers deserve reasonable fees
for Organic certification
and support from our state house in
order to continue building a strong New
Hampshire brand and identity for organic
products that's it thank you thank you
any questions thank you very much
appreciate
it I now call uh Sarah
Palmer good
morning
good morning thank you for having
me my name is Sarah Palmer I own open
Woods Farm in Grafton New Hampshire open
Woods is a vegetable farm that receives
Organic certification through the New
Hampshire Department of Agriculture food
and markets today I'm testifying on
behalf of HB
1184 I'm a certified organic vegetable
grower because as a consumer in the
modern food food World navigating label
designations like allnatural or humanely
raised or sustainable I value clearly
defined certifications and real
accountability over vague terms that are
often intentionally misleading you
should ask me about how I grow your food
I'd love to tell you all about it we can
talk about cover cropping and compost
use and highly erodable land for the
next two hours but beyond our long and
overly detailed conversation everything
that I tell you about my growing
practices is backed up by my USDA
organic certification
accountability in the 10 years that I
spent farming for other people and in
the 5 years that I've been farming as my
own business I have never experienced
such a challenging
season entering my third season as
certified organic by New Hampshire damp
I rely on the New Hampshire organic
brand to build local markets maintain
customer relationships and support the
growth of the organic economy in our
state losing Organic certification at
the state level would be the final blow
in a season of deep freeze devastating
rain and relentless
wind losing Organic certification at the
state level would be another instance of
wavering support for agriculture in New
Hampshire from our state government and
it's a
mistake we shouldn't be politicizing the
food that we eat agriculture in New
Hampshire could once again be a thriving
economy that supports the resiliency
health and financial well-being of our
local
communities you've heard from others
about the history of Organics
certification you've heard about the
growing economy of Organics nationally
but this is New Hampshire Beyond
National Data from the USDA what do the
numbers look like here in our
state here are some numbers for my own
Community 62% of my total organic
produce sales come from the Canan
farmers and Artisans Market serving the
Rural masoma Valley region in 2019 this
Market had an average of eight vendors
per week with almost no produce or other
agricultural products over the 19 weeks
of Market total vendors sales were
$25,000 that's
it I began vending at the Canan Market
in 2020 through Outreach marketing and
highquality vegetables I was able to
create a local following which brought
more of the community out to the farmers
market for weekly shopping in 2020 there
were an average of 16 vendors per week
and over 19 weeks of Market total vendor
sales increased to
$667,000 yeah that was 2020 you're
probably thinking that the Boost in
sales and vendors was directly related
to the pandemic let's jump ahead and
take a look at the 2023 season one of
the rainiest seasons in recent memory
not great for an outdoor farmers market
right in 2023 the Canan Farmers Market
had an average of 25 vendors per week
and over the 19 weeks of Market total
vendor sales were
$157,000 even on July 16th with tornado
warnings vendor sales totaled over
$10,000 for the day
this Market went from $25,000 in total
vendor sales in
2019 to 157,000 in total vendor sales in
2023 that small but important boost to
the economy of the masoma valley region
began with a tiny organic vegetable farm
supported by Organic certification
Services through New Hampshire
damp by preserving Organic certification
in New Hampshire by preserving a New
Hampshire brand we are making a
commitment to our local economies we are
making a commitment to our local food
choices we are making a smart commitment
to organic Growers and consumers and a
rapidly expanding food sector we are
making a commitment to accountability
within our national food system and we
are making a commitment to the future of
agriculture in New Hampshire that's got
to be good for all of
us thank you um representative
Morris thank you thank you for taking my
question I really appreciate you
highlighting the economic value of the
organic farm I'm just wondering also do
you know um what is the next closest
place that people in this region can get
organic
vegetables um organic vegetables it
would be Lebanon which is about um
depending where you are in the region a
30 minute or 45 minute drive
um in the other direction I'm not sure
Warner coner conquer excellent thank you
yeah thank you any other
questions um I I have a question I mean
I've heard several people come and um
talk about the importance and we we
can't underscore the importance of
organic farming in the
state um in so far as
the
um availability for
program to certify organic farms in New
Hampshire do you believe um the organic
farming Community is willing to support
uh with fees the program any program
that would be run by Department of
Agriculture in New
Hampshire absolutely um I am a more
recently certified Farm I went through
the process in very recent memory um you
actually can't be certified by Vermont
in the state of New Hampshire they don't
have certification Services here I can
be certified by mafka which is Maine I
looked at their program um they offer
way more services to me me as a farmer
and it's more expensive um I would have
been very happy to pay those fees I am
only paying $150 right now that is not
why I decided to certify with the state
of New Hampshire I want to certify with
the state of New Hampshire because it's
my home and it's where I live and I feel
like we need more investment in
agriculture in general in our
state so just as a followup so if those
fees were raised in order for you to
support that program would you be okay
with that absolutely and I would be
willing to pay what other certifying
agencies ask I can't pay
$5,000 okay thank
you all right um I have one last pink
card thank you thank you very much and I
appreciate you coming in in this weather
to speak with us
today uh one last card uh is uh from uh
commissioner Shan Jasper and Ellen Wyman
from our department of Agriculture
market and
food director Wyman has a handout he'll
be passing out thank you and good
morning thank you for coming to speak
with
us thank you and good
morning I I will be primarily testifying
uh director Wyman's here to uh back
clean up if necessary and also to
provide any any other
information
unfortunately just for the record I am
Shan Jasper commissioner of the
Department of Agriculture markets and
food taking no position on the bill we
are happy to do whatever the legislature
wants us to do providing we are given
adequate Personnel to do
that um unfortunately though I think
this hearing has been come largely about
organic farming and support thereof
rather than what the bill is about is
which is providing us
funding um we should all support in my
opinion organic farming and I do not
believe that organic farming will be
negatively affected if this bill does
not not pass nor do I believe it will be
positively affected if it does this is
simply about who is going to do the
inspections you need to know that
currently we are um in inspecting 66
Farms that are doing crops but there are
47 other Organic Farms who are being um
certified by eight other private
agencies so you know that's only a
difference of 19 we've talked about
supporting farms and again I think
everything needs to be put
into perspective according to the
USDA um there are over 4,000 farms in
New Hampshire whether you believe that
or not we're still talking about
thousands of people actively farming and
so this
is 66 out of those those thousands so we
certainly uh think they're important the
question is a matter of
resources um you also I think should
know that besides New Hampshire out of
the other 49 states there are only 12
States who are doing any organic
certifications on the state level we
have been working with NOA New Hampshire
since late summer talking about this
possibility and what are the options to
have certification now we know that it
is important to Farmers perhaps to
Consumers as well to know that um the
product is being grown and perhaps even
certified in New
Hampshire however even if if Maine is
doing the certification these Organic
Farms do have the option of being part
of our uh New Hampshire seal of quality
program and so that could be part of the
labeling there's also nothing that would
prevent them to putting on putting on
their packaging or their sign something
saying New Hampshire
groan
um just again trying to put this into
perspective uh there was a mention about
fees yes we do need to increase the fees
no we would have no intention of
bringing them up to the to the total
cost we provided in the handout what
that would cost and the average ends up
being
$3,300 a
farm um as you can can also see in the
handout currently how many programs we
have and what are uh optional and what
are mandatory because organic is an
either your in or your out
proposition we have not been giv doing
Justice to the programs that we are
mandated to do that is a great concern
to me and so that is why we are striving
to this point uh to try to get the
proper funding and Personnel now this
isn't just about the funding for us it's
about being able to guarantee to those
Farms we certified that we will be able
to do that you heard a little bit about
what happened when we withdrew from the
animal and processing part of organic
inspection that was really not a
voluntary uh situation for us it was
that we had lost certified people were
not able to do that um and we we gave
people a path forward with time and we
continue to do certifications to for
people until they could get somebody
else to do it but the problem is that
there is
just too many requirements it takes
about 18 months to certify
somebody and currently we have two fully
certified people with one other who is
almost there and is doing inspections
but not fully certified
so looking at what would happen if we
lost two of those people and let me tell
you the organic inspector that we
lost um before was part of what led to
the crisis that we're in that person
went to another
certifier so you know it's very much
like what we're we're seeing in in many
other things the state trains somebody
and then they they move
on um and so if we lost two people we
would be done we'd have just a hard stop
and everybody would be scrambling to
find another certifier so in order to
recognize how much time we're spending
and you see that the director is
spending about
41% of his time on this voluntary
program and about I don't know
it's oh thank thank you director um
that's a lot of that's a lot of time and
again um what happens if we lose one two
people how do we do this this would give
us that buffer I would anticipate and my
My Hope Is that everybody who works on
in the inspectional field would be
organic certified but this gives us that
additional funding so that then we can
also do the many other programs that we
are supposed to do and not doing well
um
so I need to let you know that I've had
since I've become commissioner the
agricultural advis advisory committee
has given me one piece of advice and
that is they only support the
continuation of this program at
100%
self-sufficiency now that puts me in a
problem because that's not possible we
could not have fees that would support
this program we've given you the example
of what it would take within the handout
but that is something nobody would
support we've also then structured the
fees proposed changes to match uh Maine
and that's based on acreage again but
the survey that we got
from uh NOA New Hampshire leads us to
the point where we believe that we would
lose many of the people we're currently
certifying even at that level based on
their survey survey and so that
ultimately we'd go from 15,000 to
perhaps the low 30s worst case
scenario um there is through the uh USDA
a program where organic uh Growers are
reimbursed for these fees up to
70 um 5% or
$750 whichever is greater so $750 is the
maximum that they can rece receive in uh
reimbursement uh so it's really
not
um a great situation as we're looking
this and I'm trying to look to see what
my advisory committee has told me I'm
going against the advice of my advisory
committee by not proposing fees that
would fully cover the the
program um
so again people I think I did did say
that uh we could provide seal of quality
which would let people know that it was
a New Hampshire product um so there are
other ways this is not about not
supporting it this is your your choice
we will do what you provide us the
funding to do but you need to go into
this with your eyes wide open have the
information you need and that's what I'm
trying to provide um but I I cannot
continue to do this Pro to provide these
Services if we do not have the funding
whatever happens with this with this
bill we will continue to provide those
Services through the 24 growing season
at the expense of the other programs but
without the funding it will have to stop
um at the end of the 24 growing
season and so with that I be glad to
answer
questions representative
Katon thank you commissioner I I'm just
trying to connect the dots
so I believe that you said that these
two people will be a buffer in addition
to what you currently have cor correct
so we have three full-time people who
are engaging in this this would give us
a fourth and it would give us then a
fifth part-time person hopefully because
we looked at the hours we didn't get
greedy and say oh well it's a little
over a person and a half we'll ask for
two we ask for what it takes to provide
the program now um and so this will give
us that would give us the buffer that if
a couple people left again we would have
to not do other things for a while but
we would always have enough people to um
to run this program unless everybody
left at once and obviously that's not
something we can ever plan
for follow follow
up okay so so you get four and a half
folks but you just testify that the
program goes away if you don't get this
other
1.5 and so the but you're currently
funded for the three people that's
currently in no no that is for the whole
inspectional decision division you see
on this on the sheets all that we're
supposed to be doing the organ ANC
program and and you know we've talked
about
1987 the requirements of the program
were not the same in 1987 as they were
today they continue to grow and continue
to grow and the federal government would
actually like states to be out of this
process
altogether so what I'm saying is we are
not currently doing what the legislature
has mandated us to do because if we're
in this program at all we can't do a
partial job we have to do a full job so
I'm saying I'm unwilling to continue to
do a May program at the expense of a
shell many shell programs and the only
way that I can uh fix that is to have
the additional Staffing okay I got it
thank you
sir okay representative
kulan thanks for taking my question um
yeah I'm curious why we can't um
contract out some of these positions
because from my vantage point it seems
like we're investing in training someone
and they're leaving to go to a private
certifier so wouldn't it be smarter to
just contract with the private person
and just say it's through New Hampshire
I'm sure there's the complications the
NOP does not allow us to contract if I'm
recalling our discussions correctly
that I can't tell you be more expensive
and we don't have the funding so where
would we get this funding from I mean
you if they allowed it okay perhaps but
still who would we contract
with and how because I don't I don't I
think we'd have to go to another
certifying agency and they couldn't
contract with us we've had the
discussions but regardless there's no no
funding to do this I I just adds that
there there's no funding it would cost
more there is no funding at the moment
it would cost more and we've I've made
an attempt to try to pull people back
with the recent increase in in in state
employment uh you know we got a 10%
raise and all that I I can't pull people
back so you know it's a great thought
but but to to actually put that and
Implement that it doesn't seem realistic
from what I've been you know trying to
to
accomplish representative
Morris thank you um are you confident
that if you were to get the funding that
you'd be able to retain
employees no this is not about retention
this is about making sure that the pool
is large enough that I would not likely
lose enough people at the same time and
there's always a danger here because
again it's about an 18-month program but
but this is what we've been you know
tasked with doing there are no
guarantees this just gives me a large
enough pool that we should be able to
maintain the program and at the same
time be able to do the things that the
legislature has said we shall
do representative
Penza thank you for taking my question
so how long has it have you been
operating in your current status without
having this expand
need I'm not sure
I totally understand the question let me
let me try to answer it and see if I get
so when I became
commissioner the former commissioner
told me that we were in triage mode with
everything and I soon found that out to
be very true so I have been trying to
figure out what our needs are within the
department and it has
been a couple of years years since I got
a hold of well you know the pandemic
interfered with everything but then the
director left and on the way out she
said you have to do away with animal Pro
animal and processing and then we really
began to dig into this with a new
director coming on board months later
and we've been looking at this so for
years and years and years we have not
been doing a lot of the things that um
we've been required to do some of them
we've gotten back on board to a small
degree but the uh the um feed testing
the fertilizer testing all those things
we're just doing a snippet of what we
should be
doing follow
up so you're saying you're doing a
snippet of what's mandatory and then
you're
doing you know another snippet of what's
non-mandatory
uh well no when it comes to the
non-mandatory on the
organic we you're all in or all out so
we have to do 100% of that then seal of
quality and the other program um the
Seal of quality what was the other one I
on there's uh good agricultural
practices country of origin labeling
yeah so we don't do much with country of
origin uh good agricultural practices
again that's another one that you're
really in or out because that requires a
certification that program is self
self-sufficient that program there are
fees in that and that pays for itself
and then the Seal of quality is a
smaller program um doesn't take a a huge
amount of time one more one last sorry
so then my other question has to do with
what why was the last Financial audit
done in 2017 why hasn't there been one
since because uh from what I know an
agent bigger agencies may be audited
more often we are on a 10-year schedule
so the next audit is scheduled as I'm
walking out the door and we'll provide
the next commissioner with some
guidance representative Howard thank you
madam chair um the seal quality program
if um if we if you were to dis
discontinue the organic program would
that would you be able to apply that
seal of quality program to those Organic
Farms I my understanding and director
Wyman can correct me if I'm wrong any
Farm regardless of whether or organic or
nonorganic organic can be part of the
Seal of quality program so they would
have that New Hampshire seal on their
product representative Murray thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question uh my question is around just
um the frequency with which the Fe
structure might be Revisited in the
future um do you have
a a preference for how that would be
looked at seen as what we're looking at
at right now it looks like there are
some rather large adjustments that we're
looking at so if you could speak to
that certainly um the previous director
you know that was really under her
baileywick and during my first few years
she never came forward with that really
wasn't something that was on my radar
because there were so many so many
issues for instance when I came in we
had uh 38 authorized full-time positions
and we only had 32 of those positions
filled and so began looking on that
began looking at databases and pet
vending as you all know has been bane of
my existence and continues to be and so
this was something that nobody brought
to my attention and frankly I think as
most of you knew know the legislature is
very reluctant to give authority to a
department to increase fees most of
those are found in statute and so I
wasn't even actually
aware because we weren't looking at that
this was something we had the
ability excuse me to go to jalar uh
through the rules to increase the
fees any other
questions thank you so much commissioner
for your
testimony I apologize I've been sitting
back there without anything to drink and
my voice has gotten very dry and so I
don't have a cold I'm just running out
of ability to speak I need the blue
sheet for the um for this
bill
1184 online um the online um testimony
submissions were 62 in support and two
in opposition 6 in
support
okay and um
yeah two two and on the blue sheet we
have uh one
person in favor of the
bill that was uh represent wolf with
that I'm going to close the hearing on
HB
1184 and I will now open up the hearing
for HB 1618 mandating a Cooperative
agreement with USDA for organic
certification and I'd like to call the
uh sponsor of the bill to introduce it a
representative Dan
Wolf I have several people here also who
submitted pink cards who have already
spoken um and I would advise them if
they have to if they're going to speak
to speak specifically to the bill um and
not reiterate what they have already
spoken
about in the interest of time we're
already very running late so go ahead um
thank you again representative wolf for
joining
us turn that on and then you can hear me
um these two bills are somewhat
intertwin they're asking my bill that
you're discussing now
reflects what was done back in
1987 and I've talked to
commissioner former commissioner um
Lorraine Miller and Steve
uh up in
Leon this was an in
attendent error
in the language of the bill where I am
deleting the word May and inserting
shell both Steve Taylor and Lorraine
Miller Merl said that they expected this
program to be
continuing it wasn't a choice whether it
could be
dropped it has been dropped three of the
four Scopes have now been
dropped so the only thing that is being
certified presently is
crops better than nothing I also certify
my
hay you cannot have a hard
stop the state did this two years ago
when they gave up handlers and
processors egg producers are called
handlers because they put it in a box um
we were given less than six weeks to
find another
certifier I I think that the
legislature should be directing the
Department of
Agriculture to continue a program that
has been running for
years you cannot just give it
up and let the farmers go
away also just as an aside it is
difficult to
comply with USDA NOP Etc and I
sympathize with director Wyman and
commissioner Jasper having to put up
with the federal
rules we talk about a
little certificate that says steal seal
of
quality it's great I'd love to put it on
my egg things but you cannot put it on
an egg carton under NP rules there b if
I'm certified as I am under mafka main
organic Farmers
Association I cannot put anything other
than the main seal on my thumb so what I
am asking very simply and I totally
don't believe that it is right to have
the fiscal note because we've got a
program
going and that fiscal note should not is
part of this bill it's asking to
continue what we have been
doing
for
30 uh 1987 37 years almost 38
years very simple request to
change May to
Shell okay thank you any other questions
from the
committee seeing none oh
representative Bixby so so the
um the bill as it is written
uh uh by just Chang that uh May to a
sha would require that all four Scopes
be uh be covered I don't believe that at
all okay uh so um if in the process of
reading the bill and getting uh advice
from um buers Etc we find that uh that
the by putting the sh there would
require that all four Scopes be covered
would you be amendable to an amendment
that would just make it go to crops I
would be and commissioner Jasper and I
discussed it I have prepared that
Amendment if that is the committee's
wish to uh go to to that because some
sort of Oro Organic certification is
better than none and commissioner Jasper
provided me with
um an amendment but I'm not prepared to
deliver it now until unless that's where
the committee's choice is okay so we're
going to be having a work this is an
informational uh we're going to be
having a work session on all of our
bills on the 30 31st first so uh maybe
you could provide that to us so that we
could include that in our deliberations
thank
you the 31st will be a work
session thank you I think that would be
the time to present
it okay thank you any other
questions appreciate it representative
wolf thank you madam chairman thank you
I'd like to call now Joyce
Ford who has requested two and a half
minutes
oh I'm sorry I'm
to
his primary testifier didn't show up
either so he was more than happy with
that I'm
sorry ah okay um Madam chair members of
the committee thank you for allowing me
to speak my name is Joyce Ford uh from
Hillsboro New
Hampshire um I'm just going to kind of
summarize some of what I've written in
there because we've heard some of it
before um about the for Scopes uh that
this bill would uh mandate which would
be crops wild crops livestock and
processing
handling um and each of these Scopes
require that the Personnel inspecting
and reviewing those files would be
trained for those particular
Scopes um and as we've heard in October
2021 the New Hampshire Department of
Agriculture damp stopped their Organic
certification for three of those scopes
for wild crops livestock and processing
handling and all of these operations uh
certified for these Scopes had to get
certified by another ACA within 60 days
I heard Dan representative Dan Wolf say
he had to do it within six weeks and the
department was is mandated also by law
by federal law to assist those uh
certifying operations to get certified
by another ACA this is not an easy task
the application process is lengthy and
uh new on-site inspections had to be
done inspections are mandated in the
federal law for annual inspection I
heard uh commissioner uh Jasper state
that it's an 18-month process this is
really a 12-month process
um but anyway to to have that
transferred to another certifier during
that short period of time was a big
hardship on these Farms New Hampshire
Organic Farms often grow crops they
raise livestock for meat eggs or dairy
products and have an on Farm Processing
operation to give added value to their
organic products I've already in my
three years of living here in New
Hampshire have already visited several
farms uh certified organic Farms um that
I buy product from and they have all
these types of Scopes that they need to
get certified by um for an example an
organic farm that's growing vegetables
and raising meat chickens and processing
those chickens they have to have
certification for all three of those
Scopes crops livestock and processing
and they pay the certification fees for
all three of these
Scopes um so by discontinuing these
three Scopes the department has
decreased their fee income to fund this
program considerably over the last
couple of
years um I would also state that I've
been in kind of involved in this with
NOA New Hampshire uh over the last year
and um the um NOP operates an organic
Integrity database that lists all the
organic farmers and the summer when I
was reviewing it there was about 132
Farms that were certified organic um uh
in the state of of New Hampshire but not
necessarily by
damp consequently in 2023 we have now
seen the number of certified operators
dramatically decreased to less than 70
and so discontinuation of those three
Scopes is partially responsible for the
pro the programs funding problems so for
that reason I feel like if you if the
department had a full program with all
four Scopes um they I support this um
bill that would reinstate accreditation
for their Organic certification thank
you thank you any
questions and I am a retired certified
organic farmer too okay thank you for
that okay appreciate you uh speaking on
that bill and now I am asking Jim Riddle
to come and speak for one
minute thank you madam chair members of
the committee Jim Riddle
Hillsboro uh and yes I'm speaking uh in
support of the bill as written uh and my
understanding is it would restore all
four Scopes um and that would make damp
a full service certification program and
as was previously mentioned uh many
Organic Farms operate more than just
crops they operate uh uh some Livestock
in addition or possibly on Farm
Processing and uh the discontinuation of
those Scopes has uh created upheaval for
those Farms additional costs additional
paperwork um and uh really damage the
long-term viability of damps Organic
certification program H and it's really
important when you're engaged in organic
agriculture that you're not just
operating alone you need essential
Services whether it's butchering or
dairy uh processing cheese making seed
cleaning flower Milling Etc and the more
services that um damp can provide the
stronger position they'll be and the
better they can meet the needs of not
just the organic farming Community but
all of the citizens of the State of New
Hampshire thank you thank you questions
from the
committee seeing none I now ask
um M CB to come and speak again for one
minute
thank you again for this opportunity and
uh my name's Nikki colb I'm the
operations director at NOA New Hampshire
we heard already about the impact of um
the Scopes that were dropped in 2021 and
the impact on farmers and The Organic
certification program as well as um
organic and the agricultural Economic
Opportunity of organic in the state and
Nation so we won't um go over that again
uh today the department of agricultural
markets and food is facing the possible
end of its Organic certification program
Al together which we have been
previously discussing representative
Wolf's Bill if passed ensures that the
department would be able to continue to
serve as an organic certifier for crops
now and into the future and could regain
all scopes of Organic certification
pending approval by the
USDA NOA New Hampshire supports farmers
who want new hampsh damp to continue as
an organic certifier for crops and other
Organic certification Scopes and no New
Hampshire also sees that New Hampshire
organic farming Community is growing if
passed hb1 1618 would signify to Farmers
and eaters that the state is willing to
invest in the agricultural sector long
term thank you thank you very much any
questions from the
committee representative
Bixby um so one thing that I'm uh
uncertain of is uh whether um if if we
passed the um the bill with a sha
language in it uh and that required all
four Scopes to be uh to be handled by
the department but the department was
only certified to handle props by the
USDA would that create a um difficult uh
legal conflict between the federal
government and the state
government I think that sorry um I think
that the department would need to seek
to extend their Cooperative agreement
for those other Scopes and that they'd
have to be in conversation with USDA
about it they previously decoupled and
took those Scopes away um I can't speak
specifically to the legal um question
that you asked but certainly they would
need to work with the USDA to add the
Scopes back with the Cooperative
agreement thank
you thank you any other questions seeing
none I
ask um David Trumble to come and
testify thank you madam chairwoman David
Trumble again um I won't repeat previous
testimony but I do want want to address
three things that have been raised first
is the question of can we Outsource this
without it affecting New Hampshire's
organic farmers and I got the impression
that that's what the commissioner said
was that whether you do or don't have
Organic certification it won't help or
hurt and I just don't agree with that I
feel strongly as I told you about the
history of this bill it was the
Department of Agriculture strong
commitment and support that saw this
program grow from eight farms in the
first year to almost 200 and we know now
that there's still 132 about half
certified in state and half certified
out of state the Department's role is
essential to organic farmers you heard
organic farmers testify it's the number
one way in which they relate with the
state government to just say it can be
outsourced and it doesn't matter to me
is just not
quite the reality of How It's seen from
the farmer's point of view the second
thing is the commissioner said well
there's only 66 it's really
132 out of the 4,000 Farms but how many
dairy farms are there in this state when
I was young before I started my own
business I worked on dairy farms and
there was about 300 in the state and
they started dropping and dropping and
dropping every time we lose one it's a a
catastrophe for the State of New
Hampshire and I think there's only a
little bit over a hundred left now so
that's about the same number of organic
farms in the state every single Farm
matters and counts and to say there's
only 132 organ farms in the state and
it's not a significant number I don't
agree with that it's an important number
and it's growing you heard about the top
program we have 15 Mentor mty
relationships I'm working with a young
farmer uh down in the southern part of
the state there will be more organic
farmers coming and they'll be selling
directly to the consumer we should do
everything we can to promote those
Farmers not tell them that they're
insignificant and then the last thing is
the question about the fees um even if
it's an average of $3,300
that's at least four times higher than
the other states are finding it to cost
for this program so I don't understand
why it costs so much for New Hampshire
to certify when Maine can do it for so
much less but again I go back to my
original point the if you put this all
on the farmers there will be nobody left
in the program in two or three years
it'll be not eliminated legislatively
but through fees it it won't exist so I
urge you to do the turn it from May to
Shell have the government do it but make
sure that you also keep the funding high
enough so that the farmers can
participate in the program thank
you so I have a question for you yes M
Madam chairman so then you believe that
um excuse me you believe that the
farmers would be unable themselves to
sustain this program by the
fees yes the paper that just went around
to you um Mr Wyman showed me a copy of
it my Farms fee would go up to
$6,200 under that program if I could do
it for 1,400 in Maine it would make no
sense I don't make enough money to pay
extra $5,000 for the same service and I
certainly wouldn't counsel my young
mentee farmer to sign up for New
Hampshire because it would be he just he
wouldn't be able to do it either the
program would would vanish so then as a
followup then you believe that that the
whole of uh New Hampshire taxpayers
should subsidize this program for the
organic farmers in the state that's a
great question um it's not subsidizing
it for the organic farmers the organic
farmers do what they do every day as a
as a um workers who benefit the state
this organic farming is environmentally
friendly farming we strengthen the
economy as I said earlier it's at least
at least $10 million probably at least a
thousand workers tens of thousands of
Acres it's not you're subsidizing the
farmer the farmer is doing work that
benefits the community and in reality
that fee benefits to the community and
look at every other program the
Department of Agriculture runs if we can
Outsource anything and it doesn't matter
then why why don't we apply that same
analysis to every program the department
does I I don't see why the organic
farmer is particularly said well you can
Source you don't
count okay thank you oh you're welcome
representative ger thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question it has
to do with this question about how do we
how we Define this outlay of funds right
whether it's a a subsidy or the term I
believe you used to testimony the
previous bill was an investment and I
wonder if you could speak to the ways in
which that's what this is right I mean
we're talking about uh when we
experienced the example of uh not having
food on the shelves in our supermarkets
for example uh during the covid pandemic
right part of that is because of Supply
chains because we're relying upon food
brought from from great distances and
growing elsewhere so that seems to me an
obvious example of where this is an
investment on food Security in New
Hampshire but could you speak to the
ways in which this outlay of State funds
is an investment that benefits the
entire State thank you representative
Jam um so you just indicated it's food
on the shelves it's it's employees
people who work on the farms every time
you spend a dollar locally you get a
three times multiplier at least so you
support a local organic farm that farm
is hiring local people they're buying
local that money stays in the economy if
that farm doesn't exist all that money
is going to a grocery store that's
buying something from out of state the
environment is important I I have never
felt like we want to turn this into
organic versus conventional Farmers from
day one I felt like that was the wrong
approach for organic so I don't want to
go there but I just want to say that
organic farmers practices by rule have
to be environmentally friendly so that's
another benefit that that that applies
um and then lastly the organic farmers I
feel have been because we can't use
herbicides we've had to come up with
different ways to deal with the problems
that every other farmer faces so when I
started the the way you controlled weeds
was with your tractor with sweeps and
shovels you drove over the crops with
your tractor and you kind of killed the
weeds but organic farmers came up with
all these really creative ways to deal
with all these different different types
of cultivators including flame weed and
spider weeders and that got adopted by
farmers who are not organic and now the
young Farmers have said well you know
what I've seen tarps being used on home
gardens let's expand that so they're
using these giant 100 by 200 foot tarps
putting them out on the field for three
or four weeks it kills the weeds
germinate they die they don't go in and
plow and Harrow they plant right into it
because anything that was germinable is
below that surface level they that gives
them a head start if you're spraying
herbicides you got a three-month head
start on the the weeds you can grow a
crop so organic farmers are working in
all different kinds of ways they are
benefit to the state I just think we
should be treated like all the other
Farmers it started as a small little
thing but they worked and worked and
worked to get a seat at the big table
and I think we should keep our seat at
the big
table thank
you okay appreciate it thank you um call
Tim
me it's meeh that's right you got it
right thank
you
thank you madam chairman and members of
the committee I'm just going to speak
about our farm uh is this in relation to
this Bill yes in relation to
Bill okay 1816 because we need to speak
about um whether or not we want to make
this um from a May to shall in in the
language of uh the current statute so
can you I'm in favor of the of doing
that okay
um so I just have a quick statement to
read sure so here at North Family Farm
in Canterbury we became certified
organic by the state of New Hampshire in
2005 we worked with Vicki Smith and
Janice Connor through the
program W though the program was
relatively new to the state the
inspectors did good work on the ground
level and helped the producers they were
inspecting through their committed work
we as Farmers felt supported not only by
the inspectors but by the state
with the pressures on farmland for
development we need the state to
continue to support and promote the
threatened Farmland farming economy in
New Hampshire keeping Organic
certification within New Hampshire sends
the message to our maple syrup customers
in United States and the European Union
we do export to European Union that the
state wants organic food production to
continue New Hampshire has reputation
for honoring its roots maintaining its
agriculture Integrity please help us not
lose that
reputation we organic farmers need
affordable Organic
certification program within the state
and I want to stress inord
affordable every label on thousands of
our bottles of maple syrup that we sell
each year states that we are certified
organic by the state of New Hampshire
that sends a message to that New
Hampshire cares about the quality of its
agriculture products
we have our syrup jugs
printed with our own private label each
label states that we are certified
organic by the state of New Hampshire
the the pandemic supply chain disrupted
disruptions are not over yet it has
taken 18 months for The Jug company to
fill our orders of the custom printed
jugs so we have to order for a year and
a half ahead on our jugs if New
Hampshire stops certifying our organic
maple syrup what are we going to do with
thousands of dollars of jugs with
obsolete
labels thank you very much thank you any
questions seeing none I'd like to call
Robert Johnson from New Hampshire Farm
Bureau thank you madam chair members of
the committee for the record Rob Johnson
representing F
Bureau and
we oppose the bill as the language just
striking May to
Shell our policy is to support a a a
self uh self- sustaining self-operating
program but but and there's a big butt
with with that is
that this is a a program that is very
important to a number of our Farmers as
you've heard
it's it's Central to the way they
farm and with you as you all have
previous testimony you've heard there's
a hard stop to the program a few years
back and we think the program needs a
real chance and given that it it it can
become
self-supporting what would ask is that
you do fund the program as the previous
Bill uh provided but Sunset
it give it three
years
open it up so that it's it's it's uh uh
certifying all
categories the the the farmers are going
to have to realize with that there's
going to be a fee
increase so that it's on par with moffa
and Bay State and you know Vermont NOA
those are are are bordering states and I
think they also the community needs
needs to get on board and go to those
that are currently out of state being
certified from out of state and say you
know if you if we are going to maintain
a program in New Hampshire you need to
come back or you've need to come to New
Hampshire but that all that needs time
so I think if if you and the legislature
as a whole if you decide to do that it
will give it a but again because of the
hard stop and what they've been through
uh it it it gives it a chance and we
think in that way it it can it is
important enough and I think it's
important not just to our Farmers but to
the state as a whole and and in CL thing
I just I do want to say is that our
policy for for supporting a a
self-supporting and self-sustaining uh
program is is like the commissioner said
there are a number of things that the
department currently isn't doing isn't
able to do because of of of all their
responsibilities and you you the
commissioner touched on fertilizer
testing that's something that's been a
big one for our folks uh we just just
met the other day with him and you'll be
hearing more about it is relative to
farmers markets and and how they are not
being pleased as needed because again
the agency just doesn't have the
resources so again in closing please
provide provide the funding Sunset it
give the program a chance and I I'll
close with that and always thank you for
your uh attention and and and
consideration thank you representative
Katon I'm sorry I I lost it you said you
oppos the bill does that mean that you
oppos the bill we we oppose a change in
the language of of of um because if but
we would ask that you provide the
funding to Sunset for a period of say
call three years okay thank you yet the
the other excuse me if I may Madam chair
the the other thing that I intended to
mention also um
the I think what would like right now
the way the the word it's worded such
that it's a May program with the US
Department of Agriculture and there's no
consideration there as has been previous
mentioned a contract out or work with
somebody else and would eventually at
some point like to see that that uh
piece changed and I know I know with the
the director said but I that's the first
I've heard of it that there it doesn't
seem to be the the uh uh feds do do not
approve of of of Contracting and i' I
guess I'd like a little more information
on that thank you any
questions seeing none oh representative
Bixby Sor I'm a little bit confused
about um what you're talking about
sunsetting would that be part of 1618 or
part of 1184 we about merge them both
the sunset I'm talking about the program
in general it's hard to separate with
these bills as to they're all they're so
very similar but it would be the the the
the the well the program in general the
hope would be that after that period it
would be funded in if it's making
bringing in adequate funds then uh the
department would be able to and and to
to to continue
it okay thank you
okay representative
Howard so just a point of clarification
so if you you're saying I subsidize it
for until it sunsets and then not don't
replace it with anything or correct
State goes out of out of the business of
certifying at least it would give the
program a chance again the the the that
was like like uh the sponsor said that
was a hard stop a couple years back that
was real challenging difficult and not
fair to to the participants in the
program and at least this allows them
some time to one for fees to be
increased going to a full program and
then allowing them to get like I said to
get out into the organic community and
say look you folks that are in New
Hampshire that are participating on the
state well if we're going to have a
self-sustaining program in New Hampshire
we need you and I don't think that's
been
attempted okay representative um
bman thank you and get used to that yeah
this is my first time speaking in
committee so you know let me know if I'm
doing it right congratulations you're
doing fine okay thank you um so my
question and if you're not the right
person I apologize but previous speaker
mentioned um something about the
non-organic farms and I'm R wondering if
there's anyone who knows in this state
what kind of subsidies or support
financial support the non-organic
farmers are
getting I think for the most part both
get the same when you're speaking
specifically organic yeah there are
there a few things that they they uh are
eligible for Rel relative to their
certification cost and that having
there's some cost share with the USDA
but for the most part I don't it's I
would say the the both whether you're
organic or non you're you're getting the
same availability of programming whether
it be state or federal so followup
followup sure so so then the the
nonorganic Farms aren't getting any
other kind of additional funding in any
way or any other kind of additional
support
for what um anything really just
wondering if there are other places that
anything any different than an organic
farmer would be getting okay yeah yeah
maybe to clarify a little bit maybe it's
more to the root of what you're asking
is that the organic program is a
marketing program that's not mandatory
right so that's that's the difference
why some would say that why is the
Department of Agriculture doing it and
was a choice that was made you know by
the by the department years ago um to to
to become a
certifier I know I'm not answering
question clarify there's it's more the
marketing though right I mean it's it's
different practices in in the program
practices but as far as I think from a
state point it's it's Perman it's a
marketing program that's what it
is okay thank you thank you
representative ger thank you madam chair
uh thank you for taking my question so
I'm wondering if instead of of
sunsetting the program and facing the
possibility there's a cliff then that we
fall off it seems to me there's a lot of
discussion today that this isn't the
right fee structure to begin with so I
I'm wondering why it wouldn't make more
sense rather than sunsetting and facing
the possibility of a cliff we look at a
three-year period and we talk about how
to restructure the fee structure so that
if the program is more successful and
fees are increasing on the part of our
organic farmers it's also decreasing the
amount that the state is contributing
but the state is still continuing to
invest money so why is uh that not a
preferable solution to revisit the fee
structure yeah well I I think I
mentioned that that it certainly does
need to be uh the the and commissioner
can correct me but I think the numbers
he provided you when I miss I walked in
just as this this hearing was starting
pretty much that that number of was
$6,000 per farmer as it would currently
that's basically just the current
participants based on what he
anticipates the cost to be that's not
without anybody I don't know if that's
really inaccurate I know what he was
getting at but it's not there'll be more
participation if it's a full program
it's not just crops and and that type of
thing um it's one and I guess I wouldn't
agree that it's a cliff a probably a
cliff was though the like like the
commissioner said the department did
find sponsors but it was a it was a very
quick turn around if it's if it's known
ahead of time that it's suns setting I
think that puts everybody's feet to the
fire and you know in three years or five
years or whatever you determine to be
but there's got to be a point where the
program becomes self self- sustaining
and in that's our policy that's what our
our members have
voted representative
Morris thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question um are all of the
farming um programs self- sustaining at
this point or is it a goal for them all
to be no they're not but again we're
looking at this it's a marketing program
as op
optional as a farmer I I can I can go to
I can go to Maine I can go to Vermont I
can go to Massachusetts to a certifier I
understand but it it sounds like we're
hearing that um it's very important to
the organic farmers that they are
certified in New Hampshire and so I'm
just wondering if it's um really more
than a marketing tool for them because
of the practices that they're using then
why would we want them to be self-
sustaining when other farmers are not
required to
be I would disagree with the where other
farmers are not required to be I don't I
don't understand that I mean the other
duties of the of the agency are you know
relative to Animal Health and Welfare
which you know uh relative to uh
consumer protection you know making sure
when I purchase a product I'm getting
what I paid for whether it be oil
fertilizer and that type of thing um
ensuring that um people that that uh use
pesticides and we all use pesticides
whether you're organic or not you know
when you apply a product to something to
kill it you are using a pesticide
regardless of whether it's a chemical or
not the the you know the agency is is
overseeing that program I'm trying to
think of an example off the top of my
head as I'm in front of you um and I you
know the the uh um the benefits of the
ACT development program are support all
Farmers getting people out to Farms
providing listings uh you know the the
plant health inspection type is you
you're you're inspector whether you're
organic or not
um yeah again this I think this is is
unique however you want to qual quantify
it qualify it I I'm not going to
disagree it is a little more more than a
marketing program but essentially for
our purposes here it is a marketing
program and I know people will disagree
on with me all members on both sides of
the issue we do it's a it's a tough one
within Farm Bureau but but as a majority
of our members ship this is our our
position and we we really are again I
want to stress that as I said earlier
and the commission commissioner said it
there are a number of things that the
agency currently isn't doing that needs
to be done and I I we understand that
challenge and and as he said the a huge
Challenge and I probably the director
spoke to it earlier is just the the
ability of them to maintain the the
educational requirements of the
inspectors how that's changing and there
been more burdens on that so we
understand
that okay representative Bixby yeah so
I'm I'm still a little bit confused
about what's getting sunsetted are you
talking about sunsetting the entire
inspection program or just sunsetting
the uh additional the the funding above
the fee levels well if
if I would say if you provide the
funding maintain the bill as is
requiring then sunet the program if
that's it so so are you thinking that we
should that the department should get
out of the certification process alog
together in three years no my hope no my
again the hope is give the program a
chance fund it and I I I think it could
be self-sustain we think it could be
self- sustaining self- funding if it
again if it's given the proper chance
represent bi so um but if it's not then
yes get out of it so uh the so we can
only do funding with bani and by B I so
wouldn't the uh issue of providing
funding for future years actually be a
decision for feature legislatures it it
it it would be I can't no legislature
can bind another I understand that so so
in that in that case the question of the
sunset might not actually matter because
um we the the pro that that that b
budget process would actually create an
automatic Sunset yeah I would I would
yes I would hope if the program um U
would not
uh if funding wasn't provided then then
there would be some accommodations and
recognition of that going forward by the
future legislators okay so um but just
sort of just getting back to like what
we need to do right now it might not be
necessary to write a sunset into either
of these bills in the way that we deal
with them because the the budget process
would event essentially deal with that
uh funding uh Sunset automatically I
suppose if it were okay right thank you
written
correctly okay any other
questions all right thank you very much
Mr Johnson and I now
call commissioner
Jasper two to three minutes and we're
running very
late good
afternoon I wonder if any of you could
see the steam coming out of my ears in
the back of the
room um so I am in opposition to the
bill first of all yes there was a hard
stop on the processing in animals it was
not six weeks it was more like six
months the letter and I can show it to
anybody who doubts me said within six
weeks you have to identify to the NOP a
certifier who may be able to certify
your
program so we were letting people know
that they had six months to find
somebody they didn't even have to have
an agreement with anybody just who could
come and do the inspections that's what
they needed in six weeks we continued so
most people had at least 6 months until
their
certification was done we had some
people within that period we were able
to continue to certify them so then they
had another year so the department
really got bashed on that and that was
totally unfair because nobody had six
weeks to get somebody to certify them so
that's the first thing that brought the
steam out of my ears it does require all
Scopes as representative Bixby has
pointed out I did work with
representative uh wolf to come up with
an amendment which he's chosen not to
give you you also heard oh it only takes
12 months to certify somebody that is
true if that is your primary job I am
not hiring people to just do Organics so
to have them do other work which they're
required to do it takes 18 months to get
them there in the department because
this is not the only thing we
do um loss of Revenue yeah was there a
loss of Revenue when we stopped sure
sure but why did we lose that Revenue if
you recall in the fiscal not is on this
bill to do all of what is asked to be
done is
$88,000 so the loss of Revenue was
insignificant the problem is we do not
have the budget I wish everyone would
stop talking about fees fees are totally
irrelevant to any of the bills that
we're talking about today I couldn't
care less if we bring in a dollar of
Revenue that's your job to worry about
if you want me to do all these for free
I'm perfectly happy to do it but I can't
do it without the 220,000 in the first
bill or the
88,000 in this bill so the fees just go
to the general fund I don't care overall
the Department of Agriculture if you
take away our grant programs and our
cost of care fund anything to do with
outside of
day-to-day operations I am one of the
few I run one of the few net positive
agencies in the state of New Hampshire
we do not require a general fund
appropriation to run the Department of
Agriculture we turn back $200 to
$500,000 a year on our operations back
to the general
fund so this isn't about why what
services are you providing most people
are paying
significant amount of money for what
we're doing but the state has made
choices like for the dairy program to
provide services so that people can sell
milk fine I don't care there's not
Revenue with that you can provide this
service to Organics without fees I don't
care I cannot do it without people and
this again you want to talk about a hard
stop I get two resignations today you
have a hard stop without any warning
without anything and there's nothing I
can do about it you want to put this
bill in As I Shall fine it's not going
to make any difference to me because if
I don't have the Personnel I'm not going
to be able to do what I can't do and
somebody can take the state of New
Hampshire to court for not doing it but
that will be because you didn't
appropriate the necessary amount of
money for the Department of Agriculture
to do it and I'm sorry if I'm sounding
angry to you folks I'm not I'm angry
about this discussion because I've been
talking till I'm blue in the face about
about it either appropriate the money or
don't we'll worry about the fees if you
want to have any later or take the fees
out of the law I don't
care representative
Duty thank you madam chair thank you
commissioner and I hope this doesn't
raise your blood pressure any higher but
I have to ask this question uh I mean I
keep hearing over and over again that
there's a funding problem a funding
problem and if there is a funding I mean
a resource problem a resource problem
then then why is the department a not
asking for more money and B why are you
sending money back to the general fund
if you need more resources
so as as a former legislator I know one
thing don't get greedy you get nothing I
have been building this department up
over the the last few few budgets we got
new positions this
year this was something that anybody
could have put money in this is a May
program that is not my priority to fund
over the other needs I have prioritized
the needs if I didn't have any other
needs I would do that I would also say
that for me personally
88,000 for 66 people with private
options out there is not something that
I say is something we should be doing
but we have many other
issues in the department and I'm fine to
do it but I've always said this is a
legislative decision because it's not a
department priority it's not something
that has caused us to
um have a real hole other than the fact
that this last year I said and
representative bixby's been part of
these discussions and I appreciate that
if we do not get the funding the program
will stop
so that's not much different than me
asking for it in the
budget and it that's the
reality represent pix yeah so um it
sounds like uh more important than the
$800,000 B change in the fiscal note for
this if this bill were to go forward
what we' really need to do is authorize
that increase in
positions that that is correct and I
will tell you again I do not believe
that NOP will allow us to go back and
start doing the other things and we
didn't do that just because of the lack
of funding that was part of it we were
not meeting their standards and we
didn't have the Personnel to do it we
certainly didn't have the time to bring
them on we didn't have a choice and this
was about not putting organic farmers
and processors at risk for losing their
certification that's my number one
concern in all of this all of this my
number one concern is that our organic
farmers do not wake up one day and find
out that we have failed and that they
are not certified and they lose that
certification whatever you do I want to
make sure that if we're going to do it
we have the ability to guarantee that
and if you're not going to give me the
people to do that then I'm not going to
do it so that we have a year
transition so that they know where they
can go I'm glad to work with them as I
have been with NOA New Hampshire to find
some paths to to see how we get that New
Hampshire certification on there this is
not about I support Organics I think
this is very very important so important
that I do not want to put them at
risk follow representa oh well okay
follow up represent Bixby and then
represent T so um so even if we did
authorize eight POS eight positions
there's no guarantee that the NOP would
reop our certification to those that is
correct because as I told you I you know
people talking about moving forward I
think what you're looking at is a few
years down the road there will be no
States certifying because then we can
get into the business of giving advice
and and help um but this is just not
something that the feds um want to talk
to I also want to talk about a little
bit and I appreciate um what Rob Johnson
had to say we've had insanely low fees
for years and yet there were still other
people who didn't want to hop on and be
certified by us
so if they were not willing to jump on
and be certified by us now and if we're
if we do raise the fees which it's at
least responsible for me to bring a
proposal forward why would they come on
with increased fees so I just people
have make decisions for a variety of
reasons and those others who could be
certified as chosen not to I don't think
there's anything we can do to get them
back represent
fenza so just while you were talking I
was just kind of searching up through
the United States Department of
Agriculture their um their database
which is the organic certifiers uh
profile and and there's a ton in there
so why not is is is that not an option
and maybe it kind of piggybacks on what
representative kulon was asking why not
have so for example NOA New Hampshire
why couldn't they be the certifying
agency because I mean just on looking in
this database here's one right here Bas
State organic certifiers they're right
here in in Massachusetts so why couldn't
they be the certifier and then that it
the burden is taken off of it's New
Hampshire based but the burden is taken
off of the state they're they're facing
the same problem that we're facing
resources okay right now they don't have
from what I'm told the resources to do
this now you've also heard that fees are
are lower in in other states even with
private wise would ours be so high what
I am told is that you know all of these
organic organizations have memberships
they have fundraising and part of that
goes to offset the fees um that they
charge to do the inspection our offset
would be general fund money I can't go
out there and fund raise for a
inspection fee reduction um in New
Hampshire I think the ideal thing is for
there to be a New Hampshire based
inspection whether it's no for New
Hampshire or if they can work out
something now one of the problems
and um director Wyman didn't recall but
as I sat there I did think about this we
had said well what if you know we
contracted with
somebody NOP said no we can't the the
person who does the inspection it has to
be their certification on the label we
cannot certif we cannot go out so that's
not an
option yes
representative follow I did yeah can I
just have a quick followup a quick
followup we are running out of time here
so all right it's fine I'll talk to him
after go ahead
okay thank you madam chair I'll make
this very quick first of all I
appreciate your Clarity around what it
is that the legislature is supposed to
do to provide you with the resources you
need to do your job so I I want to thank
you for that because I think that's an
excellent point uh do what is your view
uh commissioner around the idea of
changing the fee structure so in that
case you know we can have more
especially hopefully as the program is
successful more of it paid for through a
change fee structure which would help to
at least uh reduce some of the resource
requirements on the
department well my my personal feeling
is and obviously a unanimous vote of the
advisory committee which did include um
former commissioner Taylor who I believe
seconded the motion is the feeling of
the advisory committee this should be
self-sufficient the reality is it will
not be cannot be unless we had hundred
hundreds of people in this program
that's also how some states are able to
do it they have more in in I'm not I
shouldn't say States organizations
because all other than a few States
they're all private organizations and if
we had 200 you know growers in here our
fees to be self-sufficient would be uh
lower just like our Gap is
self-sufficient because of you know
their the number of farmers
participating in it so this is a a
matter of scale but as I say to me it
doesn't matter you can provide this as a
free service if you want to because
that's not my my job my job is to
provide the service and to do that I
need the resources and you need to worry
about whether you want to give that
amount of money to a program what I am
what I am told for every dollar of State
uh money available there are $3 worth of
requests so you have to prioritize not
my job not
anymore thank you very
much okay any other questions thank you
thank you commissioner for your patience
and
um calm
down we we we heard you when when I when
I lose my passion it's time for me to
quit we heard
you okay um we we are going to uh can I
have the blue sheets for uh HP 1618
and and I just say the online testimony
was 30 in support of uh HB 1618 and one
in opposition and on the blue sheet
here we have five people signed in in
favor of this bill I'm going to close
out hb1 168
I am going to open hb1
1578 and um I had a conversation with
the sponsor of the bill this is not an
early
Bill and he agreed to um allow us to
recess this
bill uh and schedule it to another time
certain we will be rescheduling um this
bill for another time and so I am
um going to um recess this
Bill thank
you and now we are uh on lunch break
until 1:00 when we will be hearing uh HB
J
for
I'd like our members to please take
their
seats it'll
be we're all
set
okay good afternoon everybody
um I'm going to open up the hearing for
HB
1182 adding certain equin practices to
the definition of animal
cruelty and with us today is
representative Reed to introduce this
Bill thank you Madame chairwoman and
thank you honorable members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Ellen Reed I represent new Mar Market in
newfields which is rocking
Hampton um I have been what you might
call an equestrian for 14 years I uh was
formerly trained at UNH in Dr and
jumping and since then since about 2012
I've
predominantly uh Trail ridden uh but
also a little bit of mounted archery so
it um everything horse related is
something near and dear to
me um before you today is a bill that
would add four common but pretty
atrocious and I think you will probably
agree equin practices into the
definition of animal
cruelty um they all four practices are
universally condemned by the American
Veterinary Medical Association and the
American Association of equin
practitioners um all of four of these
practices are used explicit
exclusively for competition purposes in
order to score higher in competitions
all four of these practices are grounds
for disqualification and yet all four of
these practices are pervasive according
to the Department of Agriculture the
Federal Department of Agriculture
because there is a culture of Silent
acceptance that these are the ways
people win blue
ribbons so in general just so you know
there are many different horse breeds
each breed much like any other animal
has a confirmation expectation of how
that horse will look and move and they
are judged accordingly even though a
horse may be bred with certain qualities
in the show ring it is often um
exaggerating those qualities that winds
blue ribbons artificially exaggerating
those qualities so the four practices I
will explain uh as briefly as possible
the first one and I have a handout
before you it was stapled kind of in
reverse order so if you go to the last
page the first practice is hoof
soaring which by the way has been
illegal on the federal level since
1970 uh hoof soaring happens
predominantly in Tennessee Walker horses
for disclosure I am from Tennessee uh
where this is probably the most
pervasive um it involves a number of
things first of all the application of
acostic or blistering chemical and acid
k seen diesel or mustard oil or other
similar things and then often times and
that will be applied to the growing band
where the hoof grows from the leg and
often times that will be wrapped in
Saran Wrap or a plastic and then a heavy
item like a chain will be wrapped around
that uh Tinder and uh eaten raw flesh so
that now Tennessee walkers are
specifically bred to have this High
stepping action when you see a Tennessee
Walker walk it's pretty impressive they
lift their knees pretty high it's very
flashy that's why they're they're bred
for that which means the higher they
step the more they score in competition
so it's not enough to just breed them to
step high they artificially make these
horses step high through pain the acid
goes on then it's wrapped in plastic
then a chain or some other heavy item is
wrapped around it so that every time the
horse steps down that chain impacts the
raw flesh causing the horse pain which
causes the horse to lift his leg even
higher than he would normally in
addition to that oftentimes they do
stacking that's the pictures here at the
bottom you can see how unnatural that
looks in that first picture by the way
and you can see the picture of the
chains around the hoofs that third
picture shows stacking and this is where
they will trim the hoof to what we the
equivalent would be the quick the
growing area of the hoof and then they
will nail uh a large block or stacks of
blocks um underneath the hoof to to kind
of modify the horse's posture and make
the horse walk in an unnatural way and
that is an x-ray of what stacking on a
horse's hoof looks
like this is called the Big Big Lick by
the way both the um the gate that they
have as well as the
competitions um this also impacts some
saddle horses as well as racking horses
this was made ferally illegal by the
horse protection act in 1970 but because
the the Department of Agriculture
doesn't have the manpower to enforce it
across all the different horse shows
across the country um it has been
pervasive even still and there's been
repeated attempts um that were
incredibly bipartisan repeatedly on the
Congressional level to strengthen that
act um including uh it's called the past
act the uh preventing all soaring
techniques it's been introduced I think
about a dozen times by both uh both
parties
and overwhelmingly supported but it's Al
it's always one person of leadership of
one body or the other but it's passed
the house almost unanimously it's passed
the Senate almost unanimously one time
it had 308 co-sponsors in the house the
Congressional house out of 435 reps
another time it had 40 uh3 Senate
co-sponsors and these include uh even
Republican members from North Dakota
South Dakota Pennsylvania uh Senator
cppo and Idaho Kansas and
representatives in Kansas in Florida
these were all prime sponsors at
different times the USDA did a study um
testing horses in these Tennessee Walker
shows for the chemicals that are used to
cover up the application of these acids
um the most recent study that I was able
to find uh the USDA concluded 67% of the
hores the Tennessee Walker horses in a
show had the presence of chemicals that
indicated that they had been subjected
to hoof soaring so that's the first
practice the second practice is called
gingering so once again some breeds are
expected to have a high tail Carriage so
uh if you look at
the the back of the first page you'll
see a diagram of a horse and you'll see
that's kind of like a natural relaxed
horses um tail Carriage but some breeds
have a high tail Carriage naturally and
in addition some breeds are considered
to be more active breeds that are
expected to look very Lively and so
there are a couple practices that are
used to artificially engage that tail in
that kind of more active State one of
them is called gingering this is where
um a costic item or or chemical usually
Ginger or historically Ginger although
they've also used tobacco uh peppers
onions um is inserted in the anus or in
Mars in the vagina of the horse in order
to irritate it to the point that it
lifts its tail um naturally a horse
would have a relaxed tail except when
washing it flies or if it's about to
defecate or urinate and where it would
lift its tail or if it's
irritated um it's also used to liven
sick or injured or elderly horses to
make them look more
lively the again it's another all these
practices are condemned by both the
medical assoc the veterinary
associations specifically this practice
in the 2007 Saunders comprehensive
veterinary dictionary um quotes that
gingering quote would be cons considered
an act of Cruelty in any civilized
Community um the third practice is kind
of for a similar purpose to lift that
tail it's called tail nicking it affects
the same breeds that the gingering
affects which are usually Arabian and
American saddle bread breeds um with
tail nicking the tendons that attach the
muscles of the tail are cut so that the
muscles that lift the tail are
permanently in a contracted State and I
don't know about you but I can't imagine
one of my muscles being permanently
contracted for the rest of my life um it
in this state um the tail essentially
comes be can become permanently
paralyzed and it leads to abnormal tail
Carriage the Purdue University College
of Veterinary Med veterinary medicine
says that tail nicking is an unnecessary
and dangerous
procedure and just to show how kind of
arbitrary these procedures are the last
practice is called tail blocking the
last two practices were meant for breeds
and for disciplines that want this kind
of lively appearance to the horse so the
tail was lifted and this this is for
Western disciplines predominantly
raining where they want the appearance
of a relaxed horse that has a completely
opposite tail Carriage where the tail is
completely still and so entail blocking
um usually just not a veterinarian
veterinarians usually will not do this
but an owner or some other person will
blindly inject inject ethanol or some
other nerve blocking agent um into the
nerves that affect the horse's tail at
the base of the tail this is extremely
painful ethanol Burns but um for
approximately four to six months it
impacts those nerves ability to work so
the horse cannot lift its tail it can't
switch at flies which causes flies to
bite them and and leads to skin
infections it can't lift its tail when
it goes to defecate or urinate which
leads to infections um but also it often
will lead to permanent nerve damage uh
tissue damage and the as a part of the
nerve damage the inability for the horse
to empty its bladder or bowels it leads
to infections and abscesses leg
paralysis in some cases and in some
cases death uh again the Purdue
University uh College of veterinary
medicine says that there is no health or
medical benefit to tail blocking and the
image here is on the front page um I
don't know how well you can see it but
that last image on the right hand side
is some of the tissue damage that can
result from injecting
ethanol so those are the four practices
they're universally condemned by
everyone except for the individuals who
engage in these competitions uh to win
blue ribbons in the hopes that uh they
will be able to sell The Offspring of
their horses for tens if not hundreds of
thousands of dollars
um I just want to speak very briefly I
know in New Hampshire it's these all
these practices are more predominant in
the South other states have outlawed
many of these practices especially hoof
soaring um but we still have owners here
in New Hampshire who own these breeds
who do engage in competition with these
breeds we don't have data as to how
often these practices are done because
we don't have a law or any law
enforcement or any other mechanism by
which we would be tracking that
information um and I just want to speak
kind of personally as to how I feel
horses are currently seen and treated um
we owe so much of our human history to
horses I don't think we actually I think
we kind of take for granted how much
horses have impacted human
civilization uh we don't understand in
our modern terms but for Millennia
Millennia horses were if you needed to
go anywhere further than you could walk
or you need to go somewhere fast horses
were our cars our trains our planes
horses in uh for constructing buildings
they were our construction equipment
they were our tractor trailers in Wars
horses were our tanks and our fighter
jets wars were won or lost history was
impacted based on whether or not an army
had a
Cavalry and yet I think horses are
probably the most treated like a machine
out of any of our domestic animals we
just expect pure and perfect
obedience um and and machine-like
characteristics and I just want to close
by reading this very very short poem
that's often read at the close to the
British horse of the Year award um it's
called the Horse by ronal Ronald Duncan
where in this wide world can man find
nobility without Pride friendship
without Envy or beauty without vanity
here where Grace is laced with muscle
and strength by gentleness is confined
he serves without servility he has
fought without inmy there is nothing so
powerful yet nothing less violent
nothing so quick yet nothing more
patient our past has been born on his
back all our history is his industry we
are his heirs and he is our inheritance
I think that horses deserve much better
treatment than the practices I've laid
out here and so I hope that you will
support Banning these practices I'm
happy to take
questions thank you representative
Reed so U let me first ask um again you
you say that um you have no data or any
information at all as to if this
practice is
even um done in New Hampshire we have no
data but the un uh the US Department of
Agriculture calls this pervasive in
these competitions and those
competitions do happen in this state the
reason we don't have data is because we
don't have a law against it so who would
track this
data representative
Penza
thank you representative for taking my
question uh when we talked offline on
this uh about this bill uh you had
mentioned to me uh uh some anecdotal
information that I would love you to
tell the committee if you haven't
already about that testing that was done
in regards could you speak to that I did
briefly mention it um the most recent
study that the department the US
Department of Agriculture has done um
was specifically on hoof soring for uh
Tennessee Walker horses and at I can I
find the name of the actual competition
the show that they were at the Tennessee
Walker horse's national celebration they
tested for the chemicals that are used
to cover the hoof soaring practice and
67% of Tennessee Walker horses at that
show were positive for those chemicals
so yes it is a pervasive act even though
it of the four practices is the most
illegal representative ger thank you
madam chair thank you representative
Reid for taking my question uh the first
one has to do with how this would be
enforced uh so what is the mechanism
here is this a matter of private
individuals who would be filing reports
who would be doing the the enforcement
one of the things that we hear a lot
about is that we are already uh
overstretched when it comes to our
ability to enforce a lot of different uh
codes uh whether it's in agriculture or
animal cruelty Etc so uh could you
explain in this bill uh how it would be
enforced in the state right so because
we are already stretched um and all all
enforcement of all laws or even rules
for that matter comes down to funding so
to the extent that we uh don't have the
resources to enforce um the proactive
enforcement of these laws so sending
people to shows to test like the USDA
did um or to kind of take you know
footage to and inspect horses then it it
comes down like any other crime to um
reports so there would be uh a number of
organizations and activists in this
state that would gladly go to horse
shows if they knew that there would be
local law enforcement willing to respond
and take video or notes or what have you
to um show that someone has has broken
the law ask a followup sure follow up
thank you I appreciate that and it's
related to enforcement uh I was talking
over the lunch break with a constituent
who is in favor of the bill generally
but has some concerns about generalities
what they see as generalities in in the
bill and and she was saying that with
with show horses right now that I guess
it's the United States ecoin Federation
USF if you show horses that inspections
are done of horses uh that violators are
fined that there is a registry with USF
so and I ask this for as a genuine
question not knowing anything about this
area how effective is the kind of
policing that USF does because it seems
to me that that is the reason why they
are doing these horrible things to these
horses and if the Federation is policing
them properly then That Should Be an
Effective enforcement mechanism the
Federation is not a a governmental
entity that is the people who conduct
the shows and there are numerous
organizations that do these shows so if
you can't win your Blue Ribbon because
you got disqualified because someone
finally told on you and got evidence on
you in this particular organization you
can move to a different organization and
get blue ribbons in that organization
and still sell your FES for tens or
hundreds of thousands of dollars so the
enforcement of law the fact that you've
committed a crime and could even go to
jail um is is effective and in fact in
2012 there was a woman a Tennessee
Walker Horse breeder in Tennessee who
after Decades of violating that horse
protection act on the federal level
finally got caught in charged with about
30 years worth of counts of violations
and ended up with a very Hefty uh
sentence so yeah it having laws against
things that we believe are absolutely
wrong is a good thing thank
you representative Murray thank you
madam chair um thanks for taking my
question so going back to the USF and
pre pre-competition vet checks they
don't necess I guess your testimony is
that they don't always do preet checks
prior to competition is that what you're
depending on the organization they are
supposed to different organizations have
different standards however that's I
mean think about the
Olympics does does the fact that you're
technically not supposed to juice as an
athlete in the Olympics stop that from
happening no because usually there's a
big culture around
um the athletes who stand to gain
substantively from from doing those
elicit substances and the doctors who
then sometimes get Kickbacks or are part
of this culture where it's accepted who
then go along with that it is the same
in the horse world again we're talking
about one full going for hundreds of
thousands of dollars and in that kind of
incentive um yeah these kind of bad
practices can often be overlooked either
as a fact of culture or
intentionally representative
kraton thank you madam chair
representative Reed thank you for your
testimony um I notice the bill has a
fiscal note which is
indeterminable what what did you find
when you went you contact these agencies
is there any it's just like it's going
to cost us something to incarcerate
these people so the LBA is the one that
contacts the agencies and Al with I
would say every single piece of
legislation I have seen over eight years
of being in this house that adds a
criminal um adds a law that criminalizes
the behavior it's the same exact
indeterminate fiscal note which says we
understand that we will have to have
obviously more manpower to police
something because you've added a law but
we can't tell you how much that is and
this is no different from every other
sing every single other one that we've
ever had
thank you followup so you don't
anticipate then anything in the bill
outside of that normal cor okay great in
fact it can be argued depending on the
fees that it may pay for
itself representative
K thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question um in listening
to your testimony and in reading the
bill and looking at these pictures which
is horrible uh it sounds to me that um
this definition of Cruelty would apply
to these and I'm going to read this to
you and let me know if you think this
works
cruelty includes but not limited to Acts
or emissions injurious or detrimental to
the health safety or welfare of any
animal including the abandoning of any
animal without proper vision for its
care sustenance protection or shelter
and based on these practices I would
think that they would meet this
definition I would think so too and yet
I don't think that there's any instance
of these being policed because it's not
explicit follow up thank you um so we
already have cruelty to animals and that
is the definition of Cruelty to any
animal and I don't believe that singling
out these specific practices especially
where some of them are already illegal
federally why would we need to list them
oh well there are very very very many
laws that are legal that something
legalize something federally that we
then do on the state and the question
then comes down and I by the way I
didn't didn't actually hear a question
but the question then comes down to law
enforcement ability because is does the
federal government come into every
single state and send federal agents
into every single state to enforce those
laws
so murder is illegal federally but
almost always if there is a murder in a
state it is the state that prosecutes
that and there are a whole bunch of laws
where it's the same um including in New
Hampshire because it does come down to
law
enforcement One More followup thank you
madam chair um also in the definition of
cruelty to animals and in our animal
cruelty laws it says a person is guilty
of a class B felony who purpose ly beats
cruy whips tortures or mutilates any
animal so I would consider this
mutilation of an animal I I fully agree
and yet although we know uh again uh
presuming the question there although we
know that it does happen and we know on
the federal level that it's a perv all
these are pervasive practices we have
not enforced it and I'm extremely
familiar with that exact piece of
Statute because it was the second bill
that I ever had passed and signed into
law law that expanded the definition of
animal cruelty to Wildlife um for the
entire existence of New Hampshire it was
uh when once we passed our cruelty
statute for domestic animals it's
illegal to for example beat your dog and
the reason it says cruy Whi by the way
is because our initial impet impetus for
passing animal cruelty had a lot to do
with the treatment of carriage horses
that's why it specifically says whips
but while it was illegal to beat your
dog it was perfectly legal up until my
second term to beat a raccoon for
example and it was um because I worked
so hard in that particular statute which
I eventually copied and moved to fishing
game title um that that has been
expanded to to Wildlife I am very
familiar with
that representative
Bixby so one of the things that I'm uh
concerned about with this is the
enforcement end of things because uh
because animal cruelty laws are
generally enforced by local police
departments and uh
the the the the way that that often
works
is that uh it's done on complaint so uh
someone calls into the police department
and they say I think this animals being
mistreated and then the police
department goes to inspect it they may
or not may not have anyone who has any
sort of expertise so how is uh how is
the failure of the uh of um that
complaint and enforcement process under
the existing laws which representative
Kad just C cited going to improve if we
have just by putting this into the
statute um
wouldn't it be more important so yeah
because I think that people are not
aware and that there's kind of a
presumption that it's not going to be
enforced because it's never been
enforced it's never been considered to
be part of that and so nobody pays
attention to enforce it if it's explicit
then we know it is absolutely illegal
the person who gets charged with it
doesn't have I mean prosecutors have
leeway and if a prosecutor can look at
the statute and go maybe it's illegal
maybe it's not because it's not explicit
then maybe they don't bother with that
but so I don't know that there have been
or haven't been any uh complaints along
that line maybe there have and
prosecutors haven't bothered to
prosecute but we know that if it's
explicit then prosecutors can say yes
absolutely this is against the law and
we're going to move forward thank
you representative Murray thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question I was curious to know because
part of um building off of
Representative Kat's question part of
the um enforcement mechanism can
possibly include the state veterinarian
have you had conversations with the
state veterinarian on any of those any
investigations complaints or concerns
around this with regard to Soaring and
those types of things within the state
not the state veterinarian but
veterinarians in in specific
veterinarians as well as Veterinary
organizations I haven't met a single
veterinarian that I've talked to to any
actually really any horse issue about
that would think that any of these are
okay
practices follow up that really wasn't
my question it was just more about the
enforcement mechanism have you had any
conversations with the state
veterinarian regarding that portion of
it no and I I mean tying back to the
more generalized you know concerns or
questions around enforcement generally
um this happens every single time we add
anything to statute that's illegal
that's a crime and I think it's
incumbent upon us
to decide what is the right thing and
what is the wrong thing and make laws
according to that and not and if we have
to fund law enforcement to do that then
we do that because it's the right thing
but we don't abide by cruel and awful
behavior in society just because we
don't want police to enforce those
laws representative
NAB thank you madam chair thank you
representative Reed for taking my
question I just wanted to clarify by um
you mentioned soaring is federally
illegal are the other practices also
illegal federally not that I know of the
horse protection act as I understand is
fairly broad which is why there's been
quite a few attempts to strengthen that
particular language with the past act
the preventing all soaring techniques
act which goes into more detail about
hoof
soaring representative Bixby so uh there
are
um various animal uh rights or rights
and protection ction organizations that
make a practice of doing some level of
Investigation of Cruelty when they see
it cropping up uh have you contacted any
of them about uh how they deal with this
issue both the Humane Society and Peta
are in support of this bill um and all
of those organizations I'll kind of
speak for all of them would appreciate
the help of the government in stopping
these practices to whatever extent they
may help out with the government doing
that thank
you all right um any other questions for
representative
Reed excuse me um I do have a
question if I could stop coughing
um so tell me again why we would
specifically
enumerate this kind of practice when we
already have in statute something broad
enough to cover all of these kinds of
cruel
behaviors um or procedures rather to
these animals I mean because then aren't
we getting ourselves into a situation
where we would be having to
enumerate a whole bunch of a whole list
of other things possibly not
capturing all of them and put ourselves
in a legislative bind
I would I would assume that we would
want to have uh like we have current
statute be a little bit more broad so
that it would um take into account all
all of these horrendous things that
you've outlined yeah and there's there's
such a thing as the balance of the
ambiguity of law right so we have
written this law very broadly I support
the language that we currently have but
it's not being enforced in the way the
spirit that I think it was written in
that broad spirit so this is why we have
including but not limited to lists and
these are found all throughout law
because we know that there are specific
things that we want to make sure are
covered but that there are other things
that we want to be more broad about in
case we haven't thought of those things
right so this is an example of this has
not been enforced it has been accepted
culturally the way as I said towards the
end of my testimony the way we treat
horses is kind of in its own set um
because of how machine like they have
been throughout Society for us and how
much we treat them like machines even
today so because it's kind of been
culturally accepted it hasn't been
enforced even though our language is
Broad enough to include it and since it
hasn't been enforced I'm arguing for
including in the including but not
limited to list these particular acts
okay so then as a
followup we are already seeing that
these are not accepted uh practices by
the veteran Maran
Association by the shows themselves um
and it seems to me that the the eoin
community is already doing a pretty fair
job of policing themselves I mean in so
far
as uh in so far as there you know if if
you're found out that you're doing
something that that you would be
eliminated from competition so yes the
veterinary Community is absolutely
unequivocally against all of these
things to say that the horse show
organizations are against it is kind
of H they will say they're against it
they have technical rules but they don't
necessarily enforce it and yes I would
say any equestrian worth his or her salt
is against these but I have equestrians
in the room who will happily testify to
the fact that not all equestrians
actually obey um what we would consider
to be ethical treatment of animals um
and in fact when it comes to
competitions it is particularly
egregious particularly bad because there
is so much money riding on these for the
winners and also for the organizations
so to say that they actually condemn is
kind of like they say it but then they
they don't really mean it a lot of
times okay so then I I just one more
followup on that
so if these equestrians in these shows
see that there is another that there is
an animal that is being mistreated in
this
way the way our current statute is
written they could report them for being
for torturing or abusing an animal and
um and report them to a policeman or to
um you know
local um animal
officer they have that at their disposal
to do that yes Madam chair this goes
back to the question I answered from
representative Tua which is to say and
and just so we're aware the vast
majority of people who go to these shows
are part of this culture and kind of
believe in these practices there can be
activists or people who don't believe in
these practices and believe in the
ethical treatment of animals that go to
these shows even with the intention
specific intention of reporting but then
what happens if you don't have this
explicitly in law is a process cutor who
receives a complaint and evidence might
then go well I don't know if I can
actually kind of you know prove this is
it worth Prosecuting so making it
explicit helps prosecutors prosecute and
helps those people who want to report
report to prosecutors okay thank you any
other questions from the committee thank
you so much seeing none I call Kurt
aronburg to testify and he supports the
bill and asks for a minute to speak
and I will be brief I'm Kurt aronberg uh
state director of the Humane Society of
the United
States we do support this bill and uh
not to get into the specifics I think
representative Reed did an excellent job
of explaining why this is
important um we believe that this is a
good step towards ensuring the Weare and
dignity of horses in New Hampshire that
are now subjected to cruel practices for
Cosmic IC or aesthetic reasons and to
win prizes in show Rings all proposed
changes in this bill share commonalities
as they serve no benefit to the horses
and are solely for
aesthetic Aesthetics in competition the
only reason to do these things to horses
which are painful cruel horses cannot
speak for themselves so we're here to
speak for them it hurts them it causes
them pain and suffering uh ethical horse
care and training practices can and do
achieve excellent results in equin
events and shows without resorting to
cruel and inhumane methods so think
these results that these inhumane
methods are achieving can be achieved
without them and the intent of this bill
aligns with the Humane Society's
commitment to animal welfare and Humane
treatment of horses in the echoine
industry that's my testimony be happy to
take questions thank you any
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony and I now call George
cook who has asked for five minutes and
has a
handout to whom should I deliver the
just pass it around
please
thank you madam chair and in light of
all of the Lively discussion that has
happened I probably won't need my full
five minutes um I'm here uh in
opposition to House Bill 1182 just for
background uh I am a horse owner I am an
active equestrian competitor in the
fields of venting and
rage as a
result uh I am a member of both the US
equestrian Federation the USCF and the
US D Federation the US
DF and those are the organizations that
promulgate uh the rules and enforcement
actions as their governing bodies for
our US Olympic sports at that level and
those rules apply from the Olympic level
down to the level of all sanctioned
competition so I'm very familiar with
both of their rule books as well in my
opinion uh House Bill 118 to is just
simply unnecessary as representative Kwa
and others have mentioned we already
have a broad and extensive definition of
animal
cruelty my and and uh that please note
that the all of these practices if you
go to refer to the horse protection Act
of
1970 uh 15 USC section
1821 uh those practices are banned and
have been banned since 19
1970 I question the um amount of
prevalence of these practices uh and the
lack of data supporting their the
prevalence of
those the USF specifically bans in their
rules which is USF gr
838 um those all of those practices
offenders subject to warnings penalties
an elimination uh these practices as
noted are not performed by veterinarians
have been banned by the American
Association of ecoin practitioners uh
they they're for for veterinarians are
forbidden from practicing those and
specifically in the case of tail
blocking if you do a little bit further
research attending show veterinarians
even have a tool at their disposal uh
electromyography and upon receipt of
complaint or a random test which is also
allowed um if failed that test will lead
to the exhibitor receiving a ban from
competition soaring
again is recognized as a practice
especially in the show ring exhibition
of Tennessee walking horses and in fact
when you go to the general generalized
definitions of soaring it they will
always refer to the fact that soaring as
performed in Tennessee walking
horses I checked the official calendar
of the Tennessee Walking Horse
Association there are no Tennessee
Walking Horse exhibits in new
exhibitions in New Hampshire in 2024 in
fact there are none north of the Mason
Dixon
line I don't believe it serves to
clutter the animal cruelty statutes with
a specific ban for practice that's
universally banned and previously
performed on horses that are virtually
absent from the New Hampshire population
and for which there are no competitions
we get into the debate which has already
surfaced in the committee that the more
the larger the number of specific
practices that you outlaw in statute the
less difficult it is to enforce the
broader cruelty statutes as they already
exist for if a prosecutor were to say
this is listed and I'm not sure about
the others why aren't they all listed
you're you you will be creating a box
that will be very very difficult for
yourself to get out of to enforce the
existing cruelty statutes my suspicion
is that house bill 1182 it's just an
attempt to create a precedent for the
ban of a laundry list of individual
items which don't have any place in
statute that is what your rules are for
and
I respectfully expect that the committee
will rule uh 1182 is inexpedient to
legislate for all of those above reasons
please also remember that any animal
cruelty investigation for the equin
population in New Hampshire requires the
presence of the state veterinarian and
so that is another resource that I would
suggest that you you check into as to
whether or not uh this addition to the
statutes will be of any benefit to New
Hampshire thank
you thank you for your testimony any
questions for Mr cook see being none I
thank you very much for thank you
testimony this
afternoon I
call sorry can't read the first name but
I think it's
Rosenfield Avis I'm sorry I couldn't
read your handwriting that's quite all
right Avis Rosenfield correct
okay thank you madam chair and
uh my background I have been with horses
my entire life and I won't give you my
age to give you my entire life but grew
up on horses and was part of the 1960
action which Mr cook made reference to
that was enacted in 1970 that made this
cruelty um to any horse and it made it
now in 10 states in the United States
that it is illegal to do this it also
made it so that you cannot sell a horse
you cannot bring it to auction you
cannot bring it to some shows however
enforcement I've heard that asked many
times here that is a question and I
support this bill because it's more
specific than the animal cruelty Bill we
need to have specifics in detail because
people it's the kiss method keep it
simple stupid well people will also keep
a blind eye when they are at shows
because as representative Reed said it's
a cultural thing and that subculture
Cuts very deep and if you want to sell
your horses in the future they will
blackball you if you have gone and
reported them so you don't want to break
that culture bubble that's a problem I
have seen it in my aqaa I have seen it
in my Thor breads I've seen it in the
warm Bloods we had to break the culture
in the AQA and we had to ban some of the
trainers for abusive treatment to horses
it was not in an animal cruelty Bill and
it did happen here in New Hampshire and
in
Maine and in nowhere in that bill would
it have been enforcable because of the
way the bill was written it is a
question in everyone's mind is that or
isn't it cruelty or is that just
reprimanding the child well the child is
1,200 lb or 1300 lb so people say well
it's kind of big should I reprimand it
that way or another way publicly or
non-publicly so again when you're at a
show and people are looking at another
horse that is being shown they don't
know if the horse has been treated
cruelty or not they have no
idea if they get into conversations
they're not going to pass that
conversation on and who there is going
to enforce it because judges want their
jobs they get paid to be
there who's going to call the
veterinarian that day it's a Saturday or
Sunday is he going to come out probably
not so you need to be specific
and you need to have this known to
everyone who is operating any kind of
horse show or event in the state of New
Hampshire it's a federal law we now need
to make it a state law like the other 10
states have and there are 10 countries
that have as well we need to enforce
this yes the culture needs to change yes
it's going to be difficult to enforce it
but we need to make a best effort to do
so and I totally support this bill
because as a horse owner we need to
protect our
animals representative
Murray thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um in
speaking about the bands um are you
aware that there are different levels of
banning as well right um lifetime banss
um and partial bands
correct
okay represent viby
yeah so um is there any uh information
or data showing that the 10 states that
have uh this in their state law uh have
a lower incidence of this Behavior than
the ones that are just being um Guided
by federal law it's an excellent
question I don't have data with me today
but if you would like it I would
certainly do the research and present it
thank you representative ger thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question uh when I was speaking over the
lunch break with a faer who had
contacted me supportive of Bill
generally but had some concerns in
particular she was talking about various
ways in which a faer might work with a
client and a horse to correct an issue
with a horse for example a horse being
lame or have something some other issue
and her concern was that uh the
treatment which will vary depending upon
the horse depending upon the specific
condition might
um leave that faer open to accusations
of of Cruelty um obviously it's not the
same as aesthetic reasons for for shows
but do you see any any concern with that
when we're talking about horses that are
being corrected because of ailments that
they may have there are different kinds
of treatments uh with with the Hooves as
I understand it that one might employ
and that this could potentially open
faers who were not engaged in what we
would consider cruelty but might open
them up to
accusations no I do not and the reason I
do not is because I myself have had
horses that have had all kinds of hoof
issues it's nature of the Beast yes
there are different ways to treat that
they can open up the blister they can
cut it Let it bleed out um they might
use a treatment that is recommended by a
veterinarian or they might use and and I
wish he were still alive to speak today
Dr Beckman was one of the best
veterinarians in our state at the
racetracks he had some of the best
methods known and he would bring on
unsound horse sound in record-breaking
time now did he do it unethically I
don't believe so I've watched many of
his methods with my horses and it was
appropriate included soaking the horse
and epson salt it included various
different methods kind methods uh
long-term methods to treat the horse
it's no different than you stepping on a
nail and what do you do to treat that
infection medications oral or
medications that you use that are
topical some even have to be injected so
no I don't see a faer being at risk
unless of course you do find a Faria who
is cruly truly cruy treating the horse
with a chemical burn just to get an
action out of the horse that will show a
different sign on the horse's
foot thank you very much
representative
Duty uh thank you so if I'm hearing you
correctly you're saying that even if
enforcement uh is limited the advantage
of this bill and uh um you know spelling
out all of these different treatments
could be educational especially in uh
rural law enforcement where they're more
likely to um come across issues than
let's say in my city of Nashville where
I don't think there's a horse in the
entire city is that what you're
basically saying rural law enforcement
is going to have a very difficult time
Discerning the difference between Humane
and inhumane treatment to many animals
not just horses um you have to be there
at the moment uh you have to be familiar
with the appearance of what the foot
would look like it's no different than
you being a specialist in the medical
field to some extent because you won't
know the difference between my horse
having had um a foot saw that blew out
an abcess versus did I do something to
that horse you just won't know because
you don't know the animals history you
haven't been there walking that path
with the animal so again
I I do think enforcement from law
enforcement is going to be difficult I
think enforcement is going to have to be
a cultural change I have seen the
cultural changes in many states and in
auctions and in other places I've been
and I've been in the horse industry my
entire life my family was in the horse
industry race horses we had saddle
breads as well so I've seen what has
occurred Through The Years what was
Humane and inhumane and as a child
started arguing it so that's why I'm
here today I'm still arguing this same
thing the same as I did with the Jockey
Club it's in Humane to do some of the
things we have done to the horses and I
believe we need to be specific we can't
be generic like the current cruelty bill
is it's too generic you need to be
specific what is the root cause of this
problem how do we eradicate
it any other
questions thank you for your testimony
this afternoon thank you call Jennifer
Parker
to speak two
minutes hello I just have a couple notes
from sparked by previous testimonies
before launching into my own um I
competed extensively for 10 years in
Eventing and I was chosen for random
drug testing one time at one sanction
show and there are also many
competitions that are not sanctioned and
therefore not governed by the USC
F uh my name is Jennifer Parker I am
owner and operator of mrey equin I'm a
professional horse trainer writing
instructor ecoin massage therapist and
Riki Master with 20 years of exposure to
the ecoin industry and a Bachelor of
Science and equin studies I have never
seen the practices of hoof soring
gingering tail blocking or tail nicking
in action but I was taught universally
through my education at two separate
colleges that these practices were
painful and unnecessary methods that
should not be used these methods are
sometimes used in styles of writing that
I do not participate in saddle seat and
park style riding whose Origins lie in
the 17 and 1800s tradition of showing
off your fancy High stepping horse
during Sunday rides in the park in this
realm status came from having a flashy
and spirited Mount and to this day the
disciplines these certain disciplines of
writing aim for a certain level of anx
excitement and anxiety in their show
horses this is where gingering hoof
saring and tail nicking come into play
to elicit these symtoms of a spirited
Mount High stepping with a lifted tail
that such judges are looking for in the
case of tail blocking the horse's
ability to visibly react to the rider's
AIDS as well as Swit their tail at
irritating flies in the pasture is taken
away these practices are used to project
a certain image in the show ring an
image not based on correct biomechanics
of the horse but instead based on
preferences fads and
styles employing any of these practices
clearly comes at the expense of the
horse's comfort and well-being I cannot
speak with firsthand knowledge of these
practices via site or action and I hope
I am never able to do so but I can speak
for the horses because I've dedicated my
life to being their voice to bring the
bridge between our two species
I can speak for the horses who
continually teach me gentler and more
harmonious ways to ride and train the
horses who have come into my care harmed
by humans to whom I promise never
again they don't want these practices to
happen to them and neither should you
thank
you any questions from the
committee seeing none I want to thank
you for testifying this afternoon thank
you um out of pink cards and I would
like to have the blue sheet if we are
done oh I'm
sorry is this
because so I was wondering if the
commissioner might be able to answer a
quick question sure commissioner
Jasper
so I I don't know if you've read the
bill um and uh I don't know if uh Dr
Crawford has mentioned this bill at all
to you but my my question is basically
this is dealing with cruelty to horses
is this something because horses are
considered livestock that the that the
he would need the the state vet or his
assistant would need to be called in uh
in order to adjudicate or to to
investigate representative BP that's a
that's a good question but I believe
that any veterinarian could be called in
you know in these animal cruelty cases
we only serve in a advisory capacity we
did not take a position on this bill
although we were well aware of it
because it is totally out of our
jurisdiction okay so any veterinarian
would be but but you need to have a
veterinarian called in
I I believe so but I can't speak with
great Authority because it was a while
ago that the bill cross my desk and I
looked at it and we talked and said okay
this this really is nothing we need to
weigh in on and moved on to the ones
that do concern us okay thank you all
right you're
welcome thank you for indulging us
Commissioner of course and as you can
see my blood
[Laughter]
pressure
okay so on our blue sheet for HB 1182 we
have two people in favor of the bill and
two people uh opposed to the bill and in
the online
testimony submissions we have 78 people
in support and three people in
opposition and with that I'm going to
close the hearing on HB
okay um moving along now I'm going to
open up the hearing as it is a little
past 2
o'clock I'm going to open up the hearing
for uh hb680
and I call uh representative
Kelly to speak with us and introduce
this bill this afternoon good
afternoon that's say good morning but
yes good afternoon yes um it's
[Music]
afternoon
snowy days make me feel like it's
morning all day I need a pink card from
you so when you get a
moment
okay just for 1680 or 1182 I was going
to speak on the previous one but
I'll I just sure that's great thank
you go ahead okay I am represent
presented Diane Kelly representing
Hillsboro 32 which is Temple Wilton and
newp switch um and I am introducing this
bill 1680 in the hopes of helping to
eliminate puppy mills um having been an
animal lover my whole life I am aware of
the problem of puppy mills um
manufacturing dogs in terribly inhumane
horrible ways um and selling them to
unsuspecting families um in retail
outlets and I'm hoping that New
Hampshire can do our part to end that by
um passing this measure um several of
our neighboring states are passing these
laws either have or are working on them
um and it concerns me that if we do not
um we will end up being the puppy sales
Mecca of the area which we do not want
um I realize that there are breeders
expressing concerns about this but um
the underlying statute for 37 col 7
already excludes breeders but um I am
open to further refining the definition
of retail to um clarify that we do not
mean
animals um from breeders rather just
animals um you know animals not breed on
the
premises
um so um it seems to me that there are
more than enough rescue animals to meet
animal loving families needs and also
responsible breeders
um and um I just feel that this is a
common sense Humane bill that helps to
end the cruel and unnecessary industry
industry of puppy mills and encouraging
responsible breeding practices and
commerce and
um providing more opportunities for
rescues rescue animals to find loving
homes um I feel at this point that
nobody needs a pet store a retail outlet
to find puppies and um other pets we
have many puppies available directly
from responsible breeders and a large
network of um shelters and
rescues and um basically I just wanted
to introduce this bill and then there
are a several people behind me who can
answer questions and speak further to
it any questions from the committee
representative ktoa thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question um you said that you weren't uh
this was not intended for
breeders however it states that a pet
vent means a pet vendor so anyone who
basically breeds dogs or cats or ferrets
uh is a pet vendor and um it says a pet
vendor that transfers
animals at retail to the public from a
physical
facility now if a breeder is
breeding and they have a farm or they
have their home that is a physical
facility right so it needs to be
clarified and I'm open to an amendment
to clarify that
further okay thank
you any other questions from the
committee thank you for introducing this
bill
today oh I'm sorry
I do have a question here from
representative kraton my
apologies I'm sorry thank you so much
and I the the term puppy
mill uh so are pet stores considered the
only ones that support puppy mills or I
mean how would you define puppy mills in
in who is it that that does these is it
only pet
stores
honestly I I think I would be best left
to people behind me to answer more
detailed questions um thank you
representative doy yes uh thank you I
don't know if you can answer this
question but under the uh a fiscal note
okay there's one thing that says and I
don't understand this out of state
Brokers with no physical facility in New
Hampshire will remain a viable business
option I'm Happ
do we understand what that means to be
honest I'm having a little bit of
trouble hearing you I have even with
hearing aids I have trouble hearing and
The Mask makes it where I can't read
lips oh okay okay is that better a
little bit Yeah okay great so under the
the fiscal note uh the third from the
bottom it says outof State Brokers with
no physical facility in New Hampshire
will remain a viable business option do
you know what that addresses or what
that means I would imagine that in
addressing this it means people um um
puppy mill type breeders from out of
state will still be able to bring
puppies into retail establishments but
um I'm sure okay okay thank you so I
don't need a pain card because you
switch that one
okay next person I'd like to call up is
um Kurt aronberg from the Humane Society
of the United States
thank you I'm Kurt aronberg I'm the
state director of the Humane Society of
the United States here in support of
this
bill and uh you know we've already heard
a lot of conversation about this bill um
in both bodies and what we have learned
so far in the robust discussion is that
uh we probably should think about
refining the definition of
retail we would recommend that it would
read retail pet store means a pet vendor
that transfers dogs or cats not breed on
the premises at retail to the public
from a physical
facility retail pet store does not
include an animal shelter facility or a
pet vendor that sells only such animals
that he has produced and raised so we
believe that that would
effectively
cover um responsible breeders in the
state
um now there was also concern raised
about shelters that buy dogs from puppy
mills most shelters in New Hampshire
operate responsibly while doing the
life-saving and often thankless work of
caring for and rehoming animals puppy
selling pet stores on the other hand buy
puppies from puppy mills that churn out
as many puppies as possible with no
regard for the health and well-being of
their breeding dogs or their offspring
nor for the public who will end up with
unhealthy pets if there are shelters in
New Hampshire that are buying dogs from
puppy mills the general court might
consider legislation that prohibits this
practice as no shelter should be putting
money into the cruel puppy mill pipeline
but this bill is not about
that curiously the opposition to the
bill presented doomsday scenarios about
pet acquisition even though this bill
allows existing pet stores to keep
selling puppies as such the bill
preserves pet stores as an option for
buying a dog or cat in the five
communities that currently have such
stores it is notable however that even
in states where dozens of stores were
required to stop selling puppies there
is no evidence of increased online sales
plus since 2013 the United States
Department of Agriculture has regulated
those selling puppies
online just as it regulates those who
sell puppies to pet
stores data shows that USDA licensed
commercial breeders who sell puppies
through pet stores and online are
currently breeding 30,000 plus fewer
dogs than they were 10 years ago if pet
store laws that have been enacted during
this time simply shifted the market from
pet stores to online USDA license
facilities wouldn't have significantly
shrunk these laws are effective in
stopping the cruel practices of puppy
mills that pervade this industry
now New Hampshire is home to a wide
range of responsible breeders I think
you'll hear from some of them today if
you ask them questions you'll find out
how responsible they are who sell
directly to interested buyers that
aren't afraid to show them how their
dogs are raised unlike these pet
stores seeking out local breeders has
always been the way many New Hampshire
residents find the puppy of their choice
their hunting dogs Etc
and this is certainly true for show dogs
hunting dogs as I said and service
animals plus there is a growing movement
to increase and support small scale
responsible responsible breeding the
functional dog collaborative based here
in New Hampshire is a new group that
does just
that I'll try to be brief I'm going to
finish soon another Topic at the hearing
was merely regulating the sale of
puppies and pet stores if the committee
would like to place regulations on
existing pup p puppy selling stores it
is crucial these regulations are not
viewed as negating the need to stop
additional pet stores from selling
puppies if additional puppy stores are
allowed to open in New Hampshire they
will bring with them many animal welfare
and consumer protection
problems even if it was possible to
ensure puppies came from Humane
breeders through regulations which have
notably been proven ineffective in other
states there would still be long
stressful transports of dogs
questionable inore treatment which we'll
hear about sick puppy sales which we'll
hear about misleading sale tactics and
predatory lending selling puppies and
pet stores is too complicated and broken
of a model to merely regulate lastly the
hsus supports laws that prohibit the
sale of dogs and cats in outdoor venues
like flea markets and parking lots
roadside Etc because outdoor sales
legislation should apply to all persons
not just pet vendors this is likely best
handled as a separate bill from this pet
store pet vendor bill for your reference
Vermont already Outlaws selling a doger
cat on the side of any Highway and
Maryland
along with several other states Outlaws
selling a dog or cat at any public place
including a Street Highway parking lot
swap meet or flea market with some
exemptions and we suggest that New
Hampshire consider legislation similar
Maryland's law if you're concerned about
those types of
sales that's my testimony today
thanks representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair thank you Mr arenburg
for your testimony today I missed the
all important phrase that you thought
perhaps could be amended that began with
pet vendor
transfers something about pets that had
not been raised by
them so the the definition of retail pet
store would be such
this ret retail pet store means a pet
vendor that transfer dogs or cats
not bred on the
premises at retail to the public from a
physical facility so retail pet store
does not include an animal shelter
facility or a pet vendor that sells only
such animals that he or she has produced
and raised thank you very much
representative nap thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question I
wonder if you know anything about the
trends in pet stores in the state I mean
the one that was in Portsmouth when I
moved here as closed you mentioned there
was only pet stores in five communities
well are are you know there are only
five right now and they're Mo mostly
small scale there is one in Manchester
that opened up in the spring called The
Puppy Palace which is pretty scary to me
um they display their dogs in plexy
glass cages you can't touch them until
they come out and what they do is they
create an emotional bond with the child
mostly um and then the parent is at a
loss it's really it's really uh hard
deceptive kind of practice like a car
dealership but for kids so uh you know
they have all the same kind of things go
to the finance person oh you don't have
to have the money today we'll be happy
well what happens is you get a sick dog
that dies on you and you have to pay for
it for the rest of that term of five six
10 years whatever they uh Finance the
dog
at followup yet um you didn't exactly
answer my question do you know anything
about the trends in the state I mean has
it been well what we're concerned about
is that New Hampshire as has been
mentioned will become the place to come
and buy a puppy store dog and my
organization believes firmly and has
data to back it up that dogs sold in pet
stores are primarily dogs from inhumane
puppy mill operations from far
away representative Murray and then I'll
get to you thank you madam chair um
thank you for taking my question I just
wanted to be clear given um your earlier
testimony was that that language change
that's based on information coming from
the other body well we no it's based on
or where on objections from the the uh
breeders that we we have heard that they
are concerned that they'll be caught up
as as retailers that is not the intent
of this bill so we want to make sure
that those objections are taken
seriously and dealt with because it's a
really good bill for animals and we we
don't want to lose that if you care
about dogs if you've ever loved a dog or
a
cat you got to vote for this
bill representative
smart thanks Madam chair um can you tell
me about the state law for selling pets
uh puppies and kittens do you know
anything about that that's already in
existence well the I leave the
commissioner of agricultures here he can
tell you all about it well aren't you
the director of The Humane Society for
the the state of New Hampshire yes I am
okay so do you know about the law I
already in exist I do but that's not
what I'm here to testify on so I'm
because it goes against your
bill no that's well representative smart
we don't argue with it uh with the folks
who have come to testify so um I ask you
to refrain all right I'll tell the
committee representative
dut thank you so much you know I I never
thought about this before but do any of
the retail pet stores sell dogs not
puppies do any o do any of them sell uh
you know a a mature dog or are they all
in the puppy business because okay
yeah and not that I'm aware why do you
think that
is I don't know
representative ger thank you madam chair
uh thank you for taking my question Mr
arberg uh do you know is there any data
probably not specific to New Hampshire
but even nationally
regarding uh dogs that are abandoned
right and the the it seems to me but I
don't know if data supports this that
dogs who are abandoned by owners are
much more likely to have been adopted
through puppy mills and through pet
stores uh than dogs that are acquired or
adopted rather through licensed uh
breeders but is there uh any data at all
regarding How likely a dog that is sold
to a family who for a wide variety of
reasons whether it has to do with the
family or it has to do with the dog that
the retailers don't know anything about
not matching families or dogs Etc it it
seems to me that there are reasons why
be much higher rate of Abandonment of
dogs per purchased this way as opposed
to from responsible breeders is there
any data on that not that I have or am
aware of but I can look into that for
you and I will and get back to you happy
to do that that would be very helpful if
you could do that thank you and I'd be
happy to get back to anyone with any
questions or quizzes for
me any other questions from Sternberg
thank you oh I'm sorry representative
Bixby so uh you mentioned so you you
presented a possible Amendment to the
definition of a retail pet store and uh
one of the issue I noticed a couple of
things with it one is that
um it might not take into account uh the
those people who uh breed uh breed dogs
or or cats and do not reach the
threshold of 30 animals uh and that they
might actually end up being
considered uh retail stores under this
under that revised definition because
they're not pet vendors under state law
uh because they don't reach that
threshold so that's something that that
needs to be taken care of be care is
that something that you'd be willing to
work on certainly I I mean this this is
a suggestion um I I thought it would be
a good idea to address the issue in some
way today because it's I believe it's
it's going to come up and uh I think
it's important that the Breeders respon
we're talking about responsible breeders
and we assume that all of the Breeders
we hear from will be our
responsible um
and we want them to be covered and and
not be affected by this bill when they
shouldn't be thank
you uh representative Howard thank you
madam chair um I'm not sure I guess I
don't know why somebody would buy a
puppy from a pet store rather than a
breeder in the first place are they
substantially cheaper or so I can just
give you an
anecdotal
um in my family uh
six-year-old girl who's now 29 went into
the mall with her mother and went into
the pet store to look at the dogs and
came home with a dog named
Wall-E and and I didn't know until we
they got home and
uh we love that dog but that dog was
very sick for a long time had all kinds
of behavioral
problems um it was a Puggle I don't know
if you know what that is part Beagle
part POG was the best looking dog I ever
saw
um but these dogs are bred only to be
sold in these stores in an
emotional tight mostly to a child that
then is there's nothing what is that
parent to do and most people do want to
meet the dog have a relationship with
the dog before they bring the dog home
so these online things do not meet meet
fit that and what the perfect situation
is the rescue situation where you meet
the dog you fall in love with the dog
the dog needs a home the dog gets a home
it doesn't cost thousands and thousands
of
dollars and you know that's the
situation we're trying to Foster and in
this bill it does
encourage that in pet stores you could
have these nonprofit legitimate rescue
dogs on displays for people to uh bring
home any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you Mr
aronberg I'd like to call um uh
Commission
Jasper to come and speak on this bill he
is in opposition to this
Bill thank you madam chairman members of
the committee I am still Shan Jasper
commissioner of the Department of
Agriculture markets and
food I am in opposition to to this bill
for a number of reasons I'll start off
with so you understand the
only difference between a shelter rescue
and a pet store in law is that a uh
shelter does not have to provide a
um certificate for transfer from a New
Hampshire a dog that is born in New
Hampshire but what I can tell you is
that this is a bill that really tugs at
everyone's hearts
strings but there's no evidence before
you that there's any difference in where
the animals come
from the fact of the matter is that more
animals are imported into the state of
New
Hampshire by shelters and rescues than
by pet
stores I can also tell you that as
commissioner
that the
disproportional amount of the fines that
we Levy against pet stores or shelters
goes to
shelters
sadly last
week or actually it was two Fridays ago
now we issued the largest fine that we
ever have to anybody dealing with
pets and we'll probably we'll go to a
hearing and there will probably be some
things going but because this has been
an ongoing problem this was an
unlicensed facility which couldn't get
licensed because of the conditions I
issued a fine of $
[Music]
34,400 by far the largest
fine that was after repeated inspections
and
warnings and they just
continued to do exactly what they were
doing they
transferred you know more than twice the
limit without a license and of all the
dogs they transferred I believe it was
two actually were New Hampshire
dogs so when people tell you you know
well we don't want animals coming from
puppy mills find me something in this
bill that actually prevents that from
happening there's nothing in the bill
that does
that whether it be pet
stores or
shelters the animals are coming into
this state from Texas Florida Kentucky
and other Southern States these are not
animals that are being rescued in New
Hampshire we don't actually know nobody
knows within the department what the
conditions are that these animals are
being um raised in can also tell you
that the only people importing cats are
the rescues and they're all again from
out of state so if the goal is to
eliminate puppy mills this bill does
nothing to do that what it does is
eliminate
competition one of the shelters recently
opened a retail store in the Mall of New
Hampshire
how's that any different than a pet
store what this bill also does is
ultimately take
away a business from people yes you can
transfer it to your son or your daughter
you can keep it as long as you can but
what you may have worked your whole life
for when you cannot no longer if you
don't have a family member it's done
this isn't the way we normally do things
in New Hampshire and that may be more my
my personal view than something I should
be saying as a um as a commissioner
however that is something I think that
needs to be taken into
consideration so as you may know this is
the word forw word identical Bill to
what was heard in the senate about two
weeks
ago and I think this the Senate while I
don't know the final disposition if
there has been one they're looking at
other options and what I would suggest
is that if you're going to do something
with this bill we ought to be getting at
the heart of the problem and looking at
where these animals are are coming from
how they're how they're raised I mean if
you're familiar with what's going on in
California with uh Hogs and chickens the
Supreme Court says you can regulate the
conditions in which the animals are
actually raised coming into California
so we could do the same thing I'm
suggested we have become The Dumping
Ground for thousands of animals which
because you look at the addresses you go
could they really be rescuing that many
animals off the streets in these
particular areas I doubt it I don't know
but you receive no evidence to say
anything to the contrary can also tell
you since the hearing was you know in
the Senate was a couple weeks ago
nobody's come forward with any in
information to tell me that I was wrong
about what I've been saying which I was
expecting I would hear something
uh relative to
that but
regardless if you want to
protect animals then you need to be
looking at where they're coming from and
not just assuming that if it says it's a
rescue or a shelter that those the
conditions are different because we are
unaware of any the most common thing we
get when we find people in a shelter
rescue situation well we're doing good
good and that may be their intent but
violating the law over and over again uh
is not an ex excuse for doing
good and so you know I would ask you not
to pass this bill if you feel strongly
about doing something with it I I think
you need to really um go over with a
fine to
comb representative Murray thank you
madam chair I I did just have a brief
question you mentioned that there are um
animals coming from puppy mills from
other states and I I have no idea where
they're coming from I I okay I don't
know where any of these animals are
coming from I see I mean I know a
physical I can get you physical
addresses but I don't know what the
conditions are that they're being raised
under or where they're coming from oh I
see that was my question that you had
mentioned a list of states so if follow
up if I may sure and I might my other
question was are there animals coming
from outside of the United States I I
believe that when we've looked at some
of these things there are animals that
are coming from outside of the United
States going to other locations within
the United States and then coming into
uh New Hampshire and I can tell you that
particularly with the rescues and
shelters there needs to be a a a CVI
certificate of Veterinary
inspection we have a very very high
error rate um for the the
shelters those are
continuously uh filled out incorrectly
and do not give us the information that
we have we need to
have thank you representative
ger thank you madam chair and thank you
commissioner Jasper for taking my
question so it sounds like one to tackle
this much larger problem you've
identified a problem with shelters
sounds like we need to to to look more
carefully at that obviously there are
some issues around I assume interstate
commerce that limit our ability to to to
regulate some of that Commerce but uh
what I'm concerned about from hearing a
little bit of your testimonies it sounds
like it's this idea that well because we
can't address the whole problem then we
shouldn't even try to address one part
of the problem and so I hear what you're
saying about the larger problem and I
think we need to go further in the
direction of looking at shelters uh I
think it's it is is um it's
unquestionable when we look at the
numbers of abandoned dogs all around the
country that we are talking about a lot
of dogs that are found in communities
taken into shelters I like to think like
the the dog we adopted but so I mean is
that kind of the the response that we
can't solve the whole problem so we
shouldn't try to solve one part of the
problem I guess what I what I'm saying
to you is I don't think the problem has
been
identified people are say you're you're
being told these animals are coming from
puppy mills
but what do you have from a definition
of that what do you have as evidence
that do happen we normally don't pass
laws just because you have
some some emotional uh feelings and and
people are saying this and is that even
I mean I don't know the these could be
animals that you know you have small
breeders in Texas and Florida and
wherever who are doing the breeding
these I mean I think when we think of
puppy mills we think of places with you
know a hundred dogs just turning out
other you know turning out puppies do
you have any evidence that that is what
is happening here it may be happening in
both cases it may not be but I I don't
think we should just pass laws
without
um some evidence I do think that
ultimately it may be appropriate to say
there needs to be proof for both of
these entities for everybody who is a
pet vendor and indeed the shelters are
pet
vendors um it's it's you know generally
not our job to say well geez these
people are paying too much we don't B
ban mercedesbenz dealerships in New
Hampshire because we think people are
paying too much for a car so is that
where you want to go with this or are we
worried about the conditions which I
think are legitimate of how an animal is
raised but you can't do that just based
on testimony at least I don't believe
you should thank you representative NAB
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question are puppy mills to
find in statute or by your department or
by the department of no and even if you
think of you know that that idea of a
puppy mill being a place where you just
have you know cages and cages of dogs
are being bred turning out puppies we
don't have any of those in New Hampshire
so there aren't at least not that we're
aware of and I and I think we really are
talking about imported animals here um
so if that is a concern and I don't see
why it wouldn't be then we need to
really better Define that in general and
not just give one type of of entity a a
pass when the other one doesn't have it
um there was a question uh when is my
mind and out again so representative
kraton uh thank you commissioner I
appreciate your time again today
uh I think Discerning what you've just
said is that you have no evidence in the
five pet stores in New Hampshire of this
type of abuse is that correct or or not
correct they tend to
be fined less for conditions than many
of our shelters
are um they have at times paperwork
issues
but when it comes to dogs and cats we
have very few issues there we do have
more issues with um people fostering
animals against the law with the
conditions not being up to Snuff many
you know there are there are bigger
facilities there are smaller facilities
they're all over the board some of these
are you know people who who truly do
intend to do
good but don't have the physical or the
financial abilities to actually do
things according to the laws of the
State of New Hampshire and that tends to
be a problem so there are an awful lot
of uh things out there we regulate that
believe me if you could find somebody
who would else who would like to deal
with pet pet vending I would be glad to
pass that off in a minute but we're
doing the task that we have been been um
than given and to some degree funded
again this is one of those things where
I talk about do we do the everything we
could um probably not we'd like to do
more inspections would' like to do get
out there more but we have a limited
staff our pet pet vending our animal
database um program by the way uh is
going to be coming online soon it's
starting next next Monday testing with
some of the veterinarians so we're
getting there and that's going to going
to help but um yeah I don't have any
evidence to tell you that you know any
one type of business here is better than
the other in doing so all right thank
you thank you and uh representative ktoa
has a has a question thank you madam
chair and thank you commissioner
um I just want to clarify something so
pet vendors and Retail pet
stores do they need to have health
certificates to transfer the animals and
do shelters and rescues also have to
have the same requirement any animal tra
transferred
from a a pet store has to have a
certificate for
transfer um rescu
shelters have to have them for animals
that were not born in New Hampshire but
they get that one exemption the one
difference is if it was a New Hampshire
born animal they do not need to have
that certificate
followup uh commissioner and thank you
madam chair um why would they get an
exemption if a puppy or kitten was born
in New Hampshire when New Hampshire pet
vendors don't get that pass you would
have to ask the legislators who passed
that um exemption many many years ago
because I have no idea we can't really
wrap our our heads around that
either thank you representative
Duty yes thank you madam chair thank you
uh commissioner so um in my first term
um about four years ago we also had a
retail Bill and at that time things were
a little different and I remember my
inbox being inundated with um probably
close to 100 emails most of them from
Missouri Texas Alabama Mississippi all
uh from people who were against the bill
because they imported animals in at the
at the same time it was it's been my
understanding since then that most of
the the breeders in the in New Hampshire
uh have no problem selling their dogs I
mean most of their dogs are sold even
you know uh before before they arrive so
wouldn't that be a good indication I
mean my my question is is if you live in
Mississippi and you have to sell your
animals into New Hampshire whereas if
you're a New Hampshire breeder all your
animals are taken isn't that a pretty
good indication that one might be a
puppy mill and the other is a
responsible breeder I mean if we just
had to look at
something perhaps um but again without
knowing the particulars all I can tell
you is that animals transferred into the
state more go to the shelters than go to
pet stores can I have one followup
follow uh also during that hearing um
which was was quite crowded at at the
time I was surprised to hear from the
lobbyist from a uh an animal lobbyist um
that um shelters were buying were
getting in um animals from puppy mills
because they felt that they had to do
this to to save uh to save the animal um
would do you think that this bill should
be amended to include uh
shelters I think that
the I'd love what I'd love to see is
just Banning the import of cats and dogs
from out of state but that's the
um the interstate commerce issue that's
why I think though we
could um require certain conditions
California you can't import a hog unless
it you know has X number feet and can
turn around the chicken has to be able
to spread its wings and not hit the
sides of the cages so California was
successful in that I'm not sure that's
the best thing for you know the consumer
particularly a pork consumer because uh
they may not be able to afford that pork
or or ptry product anymore and what are
you going to do feed your kids Twinkies
because it's cheaper but at least it's
going to fill them up this totally
different thing here because this is
about pets so I have a less strong
feeling about saying yeah we could put
some conditions on how these animals are
bred and raised to import into New
Hampshire and they that would apply to
everybody um sounds like probably a long
and complicated process but um there may
be examples of what uh other states have
done and that's what legislative
research is
for thank you any other questions for
commissioner Jas seeing
none
huh oh you representative
kolin sorry thanks for taking my
question uh well thank you madam chair
and thanks for taking my question
commissioner Jasper U when I read this
bill it looks like it is placing
limitations on like a handful of small
businesses in New Hampshire and when I
hear the discussion it seems like
whatever the issue is depending on uh
how we like perceive what the subjective
problem is is that you know it to me it
seems like this bill is limiting a
handful of small businesses and could
possibly benefit the more institutional
side am I right to think that uh it
certainly would appear that that is a a
possibility possible outcome as I said I
think this is a limitation of trade
because we're not setting up you know
we're hearing that emotional part where
none of us like to hear about puppy
mills but without any evidence that um
this will do anything to that except
eventually it's it stop stops the
expansion of the the pet stores and it
eventually takes those businesses away
unless you can have it as
multigenerational that's the Practical
effect effect without any actual impact
on how dogs are raised representative
ger thank you madam chair well just a
question to follow up on representative
kulan's question uh in in today's market
my impression is that most pet stores
are chain stores now I mean I I dare say
there were very few momand popop pet
stores anywhere in America anymore most
of them as you said so when we talk
about what is it that's being uh
regulated and if we're talking about a
bill that would favor larger
institutional um commercial sites over
for example small breeders I this bill
wouldn't do that right because most uh
most pet stores as opposed to small
breeders are chain stores correct cor
you know I I'm I wish I had the numbers
here but I can think in my own community
of of Hudson there are two locations
that I believe are pet stores
so I'm not sure that this number of five
is actually correct unless they're
incorporated as shelters I'm not sure I
don't think they are but again that's
something that I think needs to be um to
be really looked at again is what are we
really talking about here how are these
ownerships uh made up some of the
larger pet stores don't actually sell
dogs or
cats um they sell things that go along
with them but this is another another
problem in the bill which we don't have
the capability of doing which is to
track the ownership how am I supposed to
track the ownership of any of these pet
stores you know if you know um Petco is
selling dogs and
cats their stock is being traded all the
time sometimes corporations are bought
out and now that's my responsibility to
figure out any of that even to
transfer um the ownership it may be a a
business that's
Incorporated and you know suddenly
somebody buys out the corporation how am
I supposed to know that it now has a new
so that's another thing that I forgot to
mention was the whole issue of the
Department of Agriculture TR tracking
ownership thank
you any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you uh thank
you jper and good luck okay like to call
Nico
wle
hi
hello my name is Nico firstly the way
that you can track it is the certificate
of Veterinary information that's what we
already mentioned that's how we find out
where these uh pet stores that buy from
puppy mills are on bailing up Benji for
example Family Pet and Aquarium based on
the certificate of Veterinary
information where they you know it lets
you know where the dogs are coming from
like he already mentioned all the
Breeders listed as associated with the
pet stores sold puppies or kittens to
them in 2021 and 2022 so 2023
information isn't here but I'm just
going to read you a just a fraction of
it Family Pet and Aquarium Somerset
Plaza Nash New Hampshire uh they buy
from amily Kimber as of 20221 2022 they
bought from am Amy kimuro of Missouri
who does not hold a USDA license Clinton
Michelle of
Missouri um Donald Dorothy odley of
Missouri it's a long list of Missouri
pretty much so yes you you can know
where these people are coming from based
on the certificate of Veterinary
information the other thing that really
needs to be cleared up is that there is
a difference between a pet shop in an
animal shelter it's in our state law I'm
not really sure um where the speaker
previous to me was getting their
information but I'll cite my source
right
here we have the New Hampshire revised
Statute
4371 or 437 colon 1 animal shelter
facility means a facility including the
building and the immediate surrounding
area which is used to house or contain
animals which is owned or leased
operated and maintained by a duly
Incorporated Humane Society Animal
Welfare Society Society for the
prevention of cruelty to animals or
other nonprofit
organization just I just want to
interrupt one moment Mr Wile um can you
please tell me what town you're from and
if who are you
representing um I'm because you didn't
fill it out on your pink cart oh I my
apology I thought I had I'm from 67
middle sex Road Mary Mack New Hampshire
okay and are you representing an
organization or yourself I'm
representing myself okay thank you for
that you
proceed okay so the next thing we should
clear up is we should all be familiar
with the economy of puppy mills puppy
mills are dog breeders that prioritize
profit over the well-being of dogs we do
not need a legal definition of them they
because once again we don't really have
a puppy mill problem in New Hampshire
anymore people aren't reading these
anymore and I'll give you the history of
that really quickly they rack up USD
violations in these other states for
illegal vet practices and neglect but
they regularly fight them off it's no
big deal and they continue to make
massive profits it's a multi-billion
dollar industry ethical dog breeding on
the other hand isn't nearly as
profitable it's an incredible amount of
work and a huge investment people choose
to do animal breeding most often out of
love for Animals there is an enormous
demand for puppies and breeding would be
unprofitable if they sold to dog stores
so it's common knowledge real dog
breeders never sell to pet stores you're
going to hear that from other people New
Hampshire used to have a puppy mill
problem a few years back but it gained
Mass attention after after this super
luxurious mansion was raided and they
found over 70 Great Danes and filthy
conditions of unbelievable neglect you
may have heard of this some going blind
in clearly suffering and starving
shortly after the news attention
Governor sununu swore we'd never see
puppy milk cruelty again and tightened
our breeding practices it seems New
Hampshire was leading the charge against
dog cruelty as plenty of States had yet
to catch up but those states that mass
breed puppies became the biggest sources
for our pet stores and a real problem
developed I mean not that the problem
wasn't already there but for example
Puppy Palace they they had a bunch of
protesters out of there they got shut
down they came right back like like when
people know where their dogs are coming
from they don't shop here and then these
Shores get shut down due to lack of
demand because now people know these are
Poppy and I'll let you know why people
don't do that um these puppy mill dogs
are often the result of inbreeding that
gives them lifelong genetic conditions
the their filthy conditions that they're
bred in regularly make these dogs sick
they make the New Hampshire residents
and dogs at interrup act with these pet
stores or their dogs ill we cannot allow
these pet stores to continue to deceive
our residents as to where they Source
our dogs we cannot allow them to
continue to treat our best friends with
such cruelty dogs have always been our
best friend and that will never change
firstly to get ahead of that information
once again um there is a difference
between the animal shelters and the pet
dealers and we need to we need to
identify how this is going to affect Pet
Shops and how this is going to affect
animal shelters animal shelters in our
state law the difference is that like I
said they're nonprofit versus these
for-profit Pet Shops so because it's not
going to limit the animal shelters it
can only increase demand for
adoption okay secondly done right this
bill will not limit breeders there are
ways to Define this bill without
limiting a single breeder in which case
just like animal shelters this can only
increase demand for our New Hampshire
breeders for example in California since
2020 only breeders and animal shelters
can sell dogs their legislature is very
similar the main difference is that they
include a definition for breeders Al
separately alongside the retail ban of
pet sales protecting breeders rights
Massachusetts has a bill just like it
underway right now it's called bill
h8266 not the only way for example the
way that Vermont does it is they they
Define it by the amount of litters like
if you if you do one or more litter then
you're a pet dealer you there's that
option too but I I'm going to support
the idea that we just Define it as true
retail buying and selling that's real
simple therefore we can easily implement
this bill in a way that doesn't restrict
breeders just like many other states
have if it doesn't restrict breeders it
can only increase their demand therefore
breeders will make more sales should
they choose to meet this demand done on
right this bill can only help readers
it's a simple matter of using the same
definitions that other states have
already utilized 15 cities in Colorado
already have retail pet store bands
that's 15 different examples of this
working and 15 different legal samples
to draw from in making any amendments
one of them adopted it as early as 2012
and the most recent just last year there
are cities and towns in M six cities and
towns in Maine that have already adopted
the retail pet store band as well
including Min Minneapolis last year
Providence and plenty other cities in
Rhode Island have similar legislations
the entire state of New York has banned
the retail sale of cats and dogs that's
pretty close to home Oregon's done it
too Washington in 2023 cities in Alabama
Georgia Idaho Indiana Kentucky Michigan
Minnesota Nevada New Jersey Pennsylvania
Tennessee Texas Utah Wisconsin and
Washington DC enacted retail pet store
bands plenty of other states were
already on that list New Hampshire still
isn't Florida is I read a bunch of these
cities legislatures for their retail ban
on cat and dog sales and they're all
pretty much the same they separately
Define breeders animal shelters and pet
stores and ban the pet stores from
selling unless the dog comes from an
animal shelter given this list covers
more than half the states in the United
States of America and over half of our
neighbors and that increasingly more and
more states and cities are adopting
similar bills it's really popular the
news articles are always the same
people's reactions are always the same
this is a huge win for everyone people
are ecstatic and proud to leave the
charge in Animal Welfare this should
come as no surprise people have terrible
experiences with puppy meals and pet
stores these businesses are always lying
to their customers and hiding behind
lemon laws only not to pay out here are
just a couple excerpts from reviews
pulled from a pet store in Nashville in
New Hampshire we got a beautiful golden
retriever which our family loves when we
got her she was very weak in her hind
legs and though she though she had been
as though she had been cooped up for
quite some time after finding blood in
her messes we ran her to a vet and found
hookworms this couple was offered their
money back however they declined because
who wants to get rid of their dog after
facing expensive vet bills stressing the
couple to tears here's another one do
not buy bought a baby Basset Hound from
here for a whole week she was having
diarrhea and blood in her stool three
weeks later and $10,000 of vet bills
into this poor puppy she had to be put
down we are awaiting compensation from
the store and considering legal action
did you hear that $10,000 in vet bills
and the dog still dies and now they have
to fight for their compensation but at
least New Hampshire has lemon lost right
because the lemon laws help these people
so much that's the problem with lemon
laws no one wants to refund their new
family member they've grown attached to
no refund is going to fix a child's
heart after they watch their best friend
die due to our lacking legislation when
you have such a great influx of puppy
mill puppies there are going to be
plenty genetic disorders that test these
laws dogs will die some will die past
the warranty period and according to the
reviews on these New Hampshire pet
stores it's incredibly common in a real
legal mess to clean up for the cat
lovers here's another one completely
broke my heart when I purchased a sweet
little kitten there a week in he was
weak in lethargic took him to emergency
vet two times for anyone here who was
lucky enough to never had to bring your
animal to an emergency vet let me just
tell you it really hurts seeing your
animal suffer like that not knowing if
they're going to make it through the
night really breaks your heart this is a
regular occurrence for these pet store
shoppers and we all know
whyley yes um you had indicated seven
minutes on your card yes um would you
wrap up please your testimony yeah
I'm going to go ahead and skip the
reviews basically no one is saved by
these lemon laws it's incredibly common
experience pet stores love to use these
as a means of promising quality knowing
full well full well their genetic risks
are lifelong and even if a lemon law
secures a family refund they still just
lost their family dog preventatively so
that's actually how a lot of our
activists get started we get screwed
over by the pet stores and then we just
want Justice lemon laws do not stop
puppy mil pups from coming into New
Hampshire it literally just changes the
subject the two final most consider
important considerations how does this
affect New Hampshire customers how does
it affect out ofate puppy mills outof
State puppy mills Mass breed and sell to
pet stores all over the country or
through online platforms when you walk
into a pet store you are certainly
buying a puppy mill puppy everyone knows
reputable breeders don't sell to pet
stores on the other hand and on the uh
when you buy online there's a good
chance that you could still run into a
breeder you could still buy from a
breeder so obviously when you walk into
the pet store you have the huge problem
of impulse buying that we've already
talked about if you get rid of pet
stores you've gotten rid of a huge
source of demand for puppy mills the
biggest source of impulse purchases when
you get rid of one source of demand
obviously the most determined Shoppers
go to other sources the three being
animal shelters breeders and online pet
stores but this weeds out a lot of the
impulse buyers can you imagine what
impulse Pet shopping does to our
shelters it obviously fills them up so
by implementing this bill we will
decrease uh impulse pet buys therefore
making sure dogs make it to the correct
homes and decreasing puppy mill demand
some people today might try to argue
that some people will go online that
this will increase puppy mill demand
that is ridiculous the pet store and the
online store both buy from the same
poppy Mills overall demands to the poppy
Mills are going to be decreased and
impulse buys are going to be limited if
this wasn't the case we wouldn't see so
many cities and states implementing this
bill now that we're all on the same page
about that how is it going to
infect can you just finish up please
absolutely our dogs won't have nearly as
many genetic conditions all the stories
I read where people get their dog and
have a die a couple weeks later that
won't happen nearly as much our Shoppers
won't be as susceptible to impulse buy
saving them heartbreak our new dog
owners are going to become more informed
given they have to actually do a little
research before they buy dog should not
be purchased on a whim our breeders are
going to see more customers our pet
shelters are going to see more adoptions
they're going to see less surrenders our
taxpayers will appreciate that these
nonprofits don't need as much money from
Grants because the shelters have less
stress our veterinary hospitals are
going to have a smaller load all dogs
are going to have a lower chance of
getting sick without the these puppy
mill dogs spreading their common
sicknesses everywhere this provides
benefit to literally everyone in the
picture except the cruel puppy mills out
of state which it will decrease demand
for thank you for your time I will
answer any
question thank you Mr whitle any
questions from the
committee thank
you I'd like to Now call George
cook and you've requested five minutes
to speak we have still several um pink
slips here so uh I'd like to get through
this as quickly as we can as time is
waning and the weather is not
abating thank you madam chair I will
attempt to make my comments brief in
addition to being a horse owner just for
background I am a hobby breeder of
Siberian huskys been in New Hampshire
for 40 plus years not even coming close
to the current definition of a pet
vendor um I'm well versed in the rsas
having served since 2006 as Governor's
appointed representative on the New
Hampshire Governor's Commission on
Humane treatment of
animals uh I represent the dog owners of
the Granite State and the New Hampshire
mushers Association on that commission I
am here today speaking for myself and
not for the commission I am testifying
in opposition to this
bill the legislature as you all well
know has worked very hard to come up
with the original definition of a pet
vendor what this bill does is this
synonymously makes a pet vendor into a
retail pet store by adding this simple
definition that you sell your dogs out
of a physical facility if you are a
breeder you obviously have a physical
facility that does not make me a retail
pet
store
what I'm going to do is to raise for the
committee the reality of the subject of
retail
rescue commissioner Jasper in his
testimony before the Senate two weeks
ago uh had some astonishing numbers in
terms of dogs that are imported to the
state of New Hampshire both by rescues
and by shelters the number is is in the
thousands 1900 1600 dogs known to be
imported by rescues and shelters retail
rescue is a real thing I'm certainly no
fan of pet stores I would never go to
one I am not one and I do not support
them that is not what this bill
accomplishes Reta in in fact to show how
out of touch the wording in this bill is
when the provision that says that a
retail pet store can have a shelter or
rescue display dogs at their facility
those are two sources of animals that
are competing for the same Market they
are competing for the same person the
only difference is that RSA 437
specifically exempts animal shelter
facilities from the regulations of
437 so if you imagine you've now got a
retail pet store
let's say the retail pet store since it
starts as a
um
um um excuse me the retail pet store
since it started as a uh pet
vendor
if
the they okay excuse me scratch that
rescues import dogs shelters import dogs
the only difference is that the shelters
are exempt from providing the health
certificates that are required for other
transfers of dogs in the state of New
Hampshire the methodology section at the
footnote of the bill specifically shows
why this bill does not solve the problem
that it reports to
solve the there is an incorrect
statement there that um no local breeder
is currently or will be allowed to
transfer more than 30 animals in a year
that is not what the definition of the
pet vendor is there is no cap it's you
just become a pet vendor when you
transfer that
if the and in fact the methodology
admits that out of state and therefore
unregulated sources of animals would
become the best option for New Hampshire
I do not believe that that is in the
best interest of New
Hampshire in fact if you go to the
continued uh extent of that logic if you
now have capped any and
all sales of dogs from facilities to be
no more than 30 dogs per
year if you have an existing demand that
is not going to diminish and a set cap
on any one facility selling any more
than 30 that is going to automatically
increase the demand for more people who
might only be able to sell 30 dogs in a
year that limits the cap that cap limits
their ability to sell enough animals to
make the financial gain that they would
like to be
making and all the while the animal
shelters are exempt from those
regulations under
437 so final thing on the site on scene
transfers and the online transfers of
dogs one under the uh wording of the
animal the federal Animal Welfare act if
you have form if you maintain four
intact females four intact breeding dogs
and make one site unseen sale then you
are required to be registered as a
license facility with the
USDA so for those people who think that
oh it's just going to throw everybody to
uh you know online sales then it's for
the USDA to step up and enforce the
regulations that are already in place
for them to enforce to make sure that
online and uh site unseen sales uh do
not have
happen I believe that the committee
would be well well served by considering
this bill to be inexpedient to legislate
and I'm happy to answer any other
questions representative
kulan thank you madam chair and thanks
for sharing your testimony so you as a
small dog breeder you know would you say
by this legislation capping you at 30
dogs could you say that this is the
institutional
side of things uh you know trying to
legislate a monopoly over your operation
if they're trying to limit you to 30
dogs what if you had a good year and you
raised 32 dogs do you think you should
be able to sell 32
dogs I yes I should be able to and I
would be able to under the law the only
difference is I would need to be
licensed by the Department of
Agriculture in the state of New
Hampshire gotcha that makes no
difference to me although I have never
in 40 years even approach that limit uh
with our breeding
program representative ger thank you
madam chair I just I want to clarify
that in terms of we run into these uh
kind of lines that get drawn right
between a
smallscale uh private transaction as
opposed to when we cross the line into a
business and I suppose it depends upon
the breed right but we're talking about
certain breeds uh that could be sold for
significant amounts of money we're
looking at 30 dogs in a year uh doesn't
that clearly cross the line over into
somebody who's doing this as a source of
income and isn't 30 dogs a year a
business level of transaction 30 dogs a
year is a business level transaction but
that does not make you a retail pet
store as redefined in this Bill thank
you any other questions from the
committee thank you Mr cook thank you
madam
chair
like to uh call Elizabeth
Stak hi I'm Elizabeth starno I'm from
der New Hampshire and I'm representing
myself
so I am here because I happen to work at
one of the five pet stores in New
Hampshire that does Source its dogs from
puppy mills and what's being said here
today is that there's no evidence that
any of these stores are getting the dogs
from puppy mills but if you look up any
of puppies on the Run Puppy Palace fetch
a pet you will find hundreds of reviews
you'll find records you'll find um
breeders that have been blacklisted and
shouldn't even have dogs at their
facilities and I even inter I even asked
my manager personally what the name of
the broker he was used and then the
broker is who's between it's like a
broker for anything else they between
the puppy mill and the pet store and he
said it was select puppies and if you
look up select puppies they literally
don't have a single breeder who isn't a
puppy mill there's been investigations
done into their breeders which are all
across the Midwest like States we've
been hearing about um Louisiana Missouri
those places came up a lot but during
the time that I worked there I saw that
more than half they were getting 28 dogs
a week and more than half of the dogs
were very sick within days of it opening
because I worked there when it first
opened so they had round worms hookworms
Giardia
coxidia one dog was was taken to an
emergency vet when he was 1 hour away
from dying and when I I quit a few days
later I had quit because my manager when
we got the second group of dogs decided
that they didn't need to be quarantined
even though they were coming from out of
state so I believe the law is 48 hours
they should be quarantined but they they
weren't quarantined for even one hour
and they were obviously sick which means
that not just the dogs are going to end
up sick but humans can get sick too and
their kids at home can get sick their
animals at home can get sick these dogs
are being the difference between a
shelter or a rescue and a pet store or a
commercial breeding facility is that
puppy mills and large scale breeding
facilities are are they're producing
dogs for profit whereas shelters and
rescues are the Imports that are being
talked about are stray animals and
abandoned animals from other states that
already exist and are being brought here
because we have right now we don't have
as many stray animals as the other
states do but if we don't pass this bill
and the other states around us continue
to then New Hampshire will become the
place in New England where everyone
comes to get a dog that that same day
for whatever purpose they want it for
and another major difference between the
shelters and the pet stores is that a
shelter cares where their dogs end up
and most of the time if the person if
the person ends up not being in good fit
with the dog they they have contracts
that make sure you bring the dog back to
the shelter whereas a pet store once
it's out the door like they're not
taking it back we have like we have the
m- in-law here but the puppy palace I
watch them refuse to take back like many
dogs that should have fallen within the
warranty they advertized but they once
they're out the door and there's room
for another dog to come in that they can
make another few thousand dollars off of
like they're going to do that so we are
not talking about um Hogs or chickens or
animal shelters that sell that sell dogs
they get from puppy mills we're talking
about retail facilities and there's a
major difference between a retail
facility and a shelter and even if we
need to change some of the wording of
this bill to make sure that actual
ethical breeders can continue to operate
as they are I think we definitely need a
version of this build to pass soon or we
will become the only place in New
England where people come to get dogs
that come from puppy mills and those
dogs will end up they'll end up dying
abandoned they'll end up at the animal
shelters that are already overflowing
and we're able to stop that so I
definitely think that we should do that
thank you thank you any
questions thank you for your testimony
this afternoon like to call Bernie
Sullivan from the Irish Terrier
Club good afternoon thank you for uh
providing the opportunity to speak Madam
chair and the rest of the committee for
listening um I'll be very brief uh um
commissioner Jasper um covered quite a
bit of my concern which was the allowing
um rescues to be um displayed in pet
stores once pet stores were no longer
able to display puppies but
um I I kind of have a question for all
of you why did you become
Representatives right why why are you
doing this sitting here on a not so bad
afternoon um listen to all of us it's
not for the money I know that it's not
for the the power and The Prestige of
being a representative in the state of
New Hampshire uh you're here because you
have some some sense of service and and
and belief in the system in the state of
New Hampshire as do I I'm on I'm on a
local school board so I get it you're
you're doing your time and you're you're
trying to do something good I guess I
don't see the point of this bill we
don't have a problem with pet stores per
se and I think a lot of this is trying
to tug at
heartstrings as as has been mentioned um
I can tell you a little anecdote which I
wasn't going to include but there were
so many sad sad stories 1968 I was 8
years old and went into a do pet store
at the mall in hyanis
Massachusetts my sister and I walked out
with a darling little samed puppy got
home my mother took one look at it and
she said turn around and bring it
back and that's because she was a
responsible parent and knew and she used
that opportunity to educate me about
impulse buying um you know not
researching what you do so I I guess I
just I ask you not to be manipulated by
the sad stories and the the death and
the dying and the all those things that
um are horrible but it's not something
that's happening here and and I think
you're hearing from a lot of citizens
that
um believe in our system that it works
and that um there are other ways to
address the problem of and and puppy
mills I think is a misnomer also they're
commercial breeders is what they're
called um across the country so puppy
mills is one of those emotional terms as
well it's not really um a defined term
so um that's basically it and uh if you
have any questions representative
paten so I just wanted to ask are you a
commercial breeder no I'm a a hobby
breeder I breed I show I've been
breeding Irish terriers for 30 plus
years um um
and sometimes I have two litters in a
year sometimes I don't have any litters
um so I'm I'm small very small scale
follow up follow up so it but you've
been in New Hampshire the whole time oh
absolutely yes yeah so I talked to uh
someone that is an advocate for this
bill and uh just really didn't have it
on my radar at all um you know in that
sense and and then I just went back I
born and raised in New Hampshire and I
remember pet stores they were in the
mall and we used to go and I remember so
much of that that is completely gone now
and to include there's no such thing of
them even in um you know big pet stores
that they have of course you know the
cats and stuff like that that are there
and they told me where I should not go
and and gave me a little bit of insight
of the reason why those pet stores don't
exist anymore in that you know what I
remember remember when I was little so
are you saying that the woman that
worked there is it's not happening here
I didn't even realize there was one here
in New Hampshire to be honest so you
know I'm I'm not familiar with with the
store she's talking about or the
situation I the only pet store I know is
up by me in Plymouth they don't sell
dogs or cats they've got Birds fish and
maybe mice or so I some some rodent I
avoid that
section there there's a reason I have
Terriers I don't like rodents um but um
yeah no I mean I I don't know her
personal experience um but I do wonder
if she reported them to the proper
authorities after finding sick animals
she gave me a thumbs up she did
representative
ger thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question and it it's
connected to what representative Penza
was just asking about I was going to say
you had stated that that we don't have a
problem I think we've heard direct
testimony that there is a problem we can
argue about the scope of the problem but
I don't think that we can legitimately
argue that there isn't a problem we've
heard from a couple of of of hobby
breeders and we've heard from someone
who actually works in these conditions
specifically and I don't think that that
testimony ought to be dismissed as as
as simply tugging at at heartstrings but
the other question about uh whether we
have a problem or not is do we wait
until we have a problem we we've heard
ample evidence that states around us and
a lot of states across the country and
cities across the country are enacting
bands like this and as we know with our
out ofate waste problem we become the
place that those things go when other
states have decided that these are not
sustainable practices so uh do do we
wait until it becomes uh a problem
because we become The Dumping Ground for
things other states have decided they're
not going to do anymore um well first of
all I think New Hampshire is a unique
State because we're small and we can um
anticipate things and work on them other
than repeatedly enacting new laws and
new laws and just getting things more
complicated that that's just part of it
but um if you refer back to commissioner
Jasper's testimony he said that there
are way more rescues coming in um than
from quote unquote puppy mills and while
that's a problem if they're given the
information they can crack if dogs can't
come in sick to the state by law so they
can enforce that um and the the rescues
I mean he he talked about or someone
mentioned retail rescue um they breed
dogs for rescue now that's that's done
in the South we don't we don't have
enough puppies in our shelters and and
rescues and dogs are being bred as
rescues to um come up and tug at
heartstrings and go oh look at the this
poor little dog it doesn't have a home
um so it's that's a problem thank
you any other questions thank you for
your testimony this afternoon thank you
for your
time I'd like to call Joan
O'Brien to speak for five
minutes
so my name is Joan O'Brien and I live in
Amherst
I'm representing myself
today um I'm just heard from
commissioner Jasper I think he nailed it
what this bill will do is it will stop
the expansion of a problematic sales um
model for
dogs and um that really sums it up right
there we want to stop the
expansion there's been a lot of talk
about the difference between a retail
store and a rescue or or a Shel shter
let's keep in mind that the retail store
has a profit motive and the shelter and
rescue in theory are not supposed to
have a profit motive they are supposed
to be rehoming homeless animals and not
making a profit on either end if they
are well that's a different issue
they're you know if they're a nonprofit
they should be you know evaluated and
audited for that we're trying to solve
the problem of the retail pet stores
with this bill seven other states have
done it 400 towns and municipalities
have done it and it's working
well we heard from Ellie who worked at
the store that it's well documented that
the majority of dogs in these stores
come from puppy
mills they can only fill their cages
with a variety of of popular dogs that
are that young by using puppy
mills they treat them like
products and the store is the preferred
Outlet because you never see where the
dogs came from from and you never see
how the mothers
live the salespeople will say oh don't
worry all of our burritos are USDA
licensed this may sound good but USDA
standards are shockingly low inspections
are rare and enforcement is is lacking
it's legal to keep dogs in cages that
are hardly big enough for them to turn
around for their entire lives that's
okay by the
USDA stores will also tell you oh he's
AKC registered so he's a great healthy
dog with no genetic defects and being
registered with the AKC doesn't ensure
that your dog is healthy um while they
do inspect some breeders there's just
far too many for them to inspect them
all and they also have an interest in uh
new peer bread dogs being brought into
the world because they can collect a
registration fee every time that happens
so I think there's a conflict of
interest there as
well
uh being licensed by the state of New
Hampshire has never meant that a retail
pet store wasn't selling puppy mill dogs
the state does not inspect the places
where the dogs come from the stores look
great I mean many of them are beautiful
and clean inside and they pass
inspections but the puppies don't spend
very long there one to two weeks tops is
what the stores want um they want to
move them out before they they're not
cute anymore and so what really matters
is where they came from that's where you
need the inspection
puppy dogs are notorious for having
health and behavioral problems which can
result in huge Veterinary bills as well
as emotional trauma the joy of bringing
home a new dog can quickly turn to a
panic trip to the emergency vet or even
the Heartbreak of a dog
dying um the a postcard that I passed
around is about a Dog Named Gus who died
at the Puppy Palace um before the people
who were going to buy him could take him
home uh they had put down a deposit on
on him they were getting all sorts of
excuses he's not ready he's not ready he
needs to be treated for this he needs to
be treated for that and then finally she
got a call the woman who her name was
Holly and she this was just too painful
for her to to come talk about it because
she's put it behind her she called the
store um they said you can't see the dog
she's sleeping he's sleeping he's on
antibiotics and the next day the manager
called and said that the dog had passed
away in the night in the store all alone
and she had a little son who who was
eight who just she said she'd never seen
him cry so hard so this is that's
emotion but that matters you know this
is this is real trauma for people who
live in New
Hampshire my mouth is dry um also I want
to say that most people in New Hampshire
hate puppy mills um if you look on the
cover sheet of the My Testimony you'll
see my group of friends and we spend a
lot of our Saturdays out trying to warn
people not to buy a dog in a pet store
because it's going to be sick um and
they're going to be lied to and um I
have a petition here with 300 signatures
from New Hampshire residents saying that
they're they're opposed to selling dogs
in
stores this bill will affect only six
retail
stores including a store that's owned by
a Massachusetts millionaire who lives in
a town that passed an ordinance against
the sale of dogs and cats in stores keep
that in mind that's one of these six
stores and as written the bill will have
no effect on New Hampshire dog and cat
breeders to sell their animals direct to
customers we need those people that's
where people go when they get lied to at
the store I've talked to them they say
you know they said it wasn't from a
puppy meal I found out it was so I went
to a local breeder we got a great dog
we're thrilled that's where they go um
it won't affect the Department of
Agriculture their workload should remain
unchanged um and in terms of keeping
track of ownership I'll do that I'll go
out and make sure I'll see if if store
changes hands I'll be sure to tell them
and then the state vetenarian same
scenario his workload should be
unchanged because the bill essentially
caps things and maintains the status quo
so ideally our state would have no
retail pet stores selling dogs but this
bill will at least stem the flow of
puppy mill dogs into the state and we'll
be doing our part to um protect dogs and
citizens thank you thank you any
questions from the
committee representative
Penza wow we're gonna be snowed in yeah
we're sleeping over no so um just
to
so quick question I I thought this only
would affect one and you're saying on
your in your testimony here that it
affects six stores so where can you do
you know off the top of your head where
those other stores are located
throughout the state um I do I do know
the six Stores um uh commissioner Jasper
mentioned the two in Hudson there is the
Puppy Palace in Manchester there's
Family Pet and Aquarium in
nashaa and there is a is that five I
forget four or five there was a man who
sells um golden retrievers um I think
he's got a retail space but he's not
like in a strip mall and there is a
store in
Lebanon quick I thought that this bill
though would be for prohibiting it for
any further ones that's right they they
will be affected in the fact that they
won't be able to sell more dogs than
they sold in the year prior to the
legislation becoming you know enacted
and they won't be able to sell their
business to somebody who's not an
immediate family member so they're the
only people
affected okay thank you for your
testimony any other
questions okay um to call Representative
Ellen
Reed you've asked for three
minutes thank you madam chair and thank
you again honorable members um I just
had a few comments based on what I've
heard um watching the hearing and the
first thing is the idea of removing the
humanity we keep hearing oh feel good or
you know sad stories or whatever but it
is our job to go back to that point to
do the right thing and so while I don't
I I believe in deciding things
dispassionately in the fact that it
needs to be objective you shouldn't
remove the idea that suffering is wrong
from your brains when you're making
those decisions so I don't I don't like
the idea that oh don't listen to the
death and the misery and the suffering
no actually do because that's important
away um um so we heard that there's no
evidence that any of these things are
happening but we we know that puppy
palace is it has had numerous numerous
complaints um especially of dogs being
sick and dying so that's evidence in of
itself but also one particular person
was told that they would be able to
return the puppy if they had allergies
they had allergies wasn't able to return
the puppy um but further and I really
appreciated the commissioner's um testim
Tony in a number of ways um he said that
he fined a couple of rescues steep fines
for um uh inhumane treatment and if
that's ostensibly the people who are
doing the right thing for the animals
the rescues um how much more is the
for-profit motive driving people to do
inhumane Behavior so that tells me that
much as we've talked about repeatedly
this is an Enforcement issue and he
himself said that he didn't have the
resources to to enforce properly and I
would say and I I dare speak for the
commissioner that he might want more
funding for his Department to do
enforcement and I think the same thing
is true of lmon laws because I think we
have a lot of situations where people
just don't even complain about something
because they don't think that anything
will be done but I think that the the
point here is not to allow a bad
activity to to remain legal because we
aren't funding the enforcement side the
point here is to make sure that this is
properly enforced fored and I have not
heard from anyone either side of the
bill that inhumane treatment like the
the conditions that exist in puppy mills
or commercial breeders commonly should
be allowed to continue I have not heard
that but I do agree so so I don't think
the answer is to Simply kill the bill I
think the answer is along the lines of
what the commissioner said which is it
needs to be he didn't say these exact
words but it needs to be more robust and
that it needs to address specific
conditions about where puppies and
kittens come
from so the point of this bill as it is
currently written and again I would
support it being strengthened to that to
that extent um is to reduce the de the
demand from puppy mills and I did hear
uh someone say that there were not small
pet stores in the state aside from these
six that have been cited I know of
several most small pet stores single
owner uh individual proprietor pet
stores uh focus on Exotics uh there's
one in Seabrook on Route One I won't say
the name because I don't know that they
have engaged in any unethical behavior
um but I do know that they're quite
large and sell a broad broad broad broad
range of animals so I just wanted to
kind of correct that so um with that I
don't imagine you have a bunch of
questions for me but I just wanted to
comment on those things thank you any
questions from the committee thank you
i' like to Now call
obber to speak to the
committee good
afternoon good afternoon chair eron
members of the House environment and
agriculture committee my name is Stacy
obber I am the government relations
manager in New England for the American
Kennel Club we are a nonprofit that is
140 years old uh we are recognized and
trusted expert in K9 Health Training uh
responsible dog ownership and breeding
and I'm here today to express akc's
opposition to how
1680 um we have more than 5,000 clubs
across the country and we have 13 that
are here um in New Hampshire I think
it's helpful maybe for me to just
summarize what exactly how 1680 would do
as introduced to the committee one it
would establish a new definition of
retail pet store that would include any
pet vendor who transfers more than 30 uh
puppies animals dogs excuse me just dogs
in a year um and has a facility this
committee actually uh four or five years
ago did significant work in removing the
legal distinction between breeders and
pet stores and having everyone licensed
as a pet vendor with that commercial uh
definition triggering for Trans transer
of more than 30 dogs but inevitably our
hobby breeders who are not transferring
even more than 30 um May in fact have a
physical facility they may have a kennel
so our concern is that this definition
would in fact apply to um not only your
retail pet store that you think of but
also your breeders here in New Hampshire
so I understand from the bill sponsor uh
that's not the intent and um I think
irrespective of that not being the tent
we the intent we still have additional
concerns um the second piece of the bill
would to would be to cap anyone that
falls in that new definition to the same
transferring the same level of animals
that they transferred the year
before and then also to prevent any new
pet stores new retail pet stores um from
setting up shop and basically allowing
them to only host adoption events at
their at their facility um one of our
concerns and I do have written testimony
and I sent it via email because there
are hot links in there to some of the
data that I'm going to share with you is
that um what we know from a survey that
the American Veterinary Medical
Association did in
2022 is that uh pet owners report that
only about 25% report that they were
able to get a dog from a breeder and
what that means is Americans love their
dogs the demand for dogs is higher than
the number of breeders that are out
there producing dogs and our concern in
what we have seen is that where this
type of bill has passed for instance in
California was the first state to um
implement it back in
2019 individuals who are unwilling to
wait the two to three years that they
may be on a list waiting for a local
breeder to have a puppy available to
them inevitably will go online to
purchase a dog and I know you heard
testimony earlier about how the United
States the USDA requires a license in
the event someone is selling a pet sight
unseen the issue is that when consumers
go online and are not able to go in
person whether that's to a retail pet
store or to a local breeder to um see
the pet firsthand to ask who the
veterinarian is to get a copy of the
health certificate when they go online I
shared with all of you a report from
December
2022 by the Better Business Bureau that
started started
tracking online pet scams back in
2017 and during the pandemic what they
saw is that people were not able to go
uh locally or to a pet store to acquire
a pet and the numbers increased to
25% in 2020 and 26% in
2026 of all scams tracked by the Better
Business Bureau were pet related that's
pretty significant um so our concern is
that people that are unwilling to wait
or can't go in person will be forced to
go online and these are not individuals
that are licensed by the USDA selling
pets sight unseen um I have a antidotal
story about a breeder that contacted me
online there was a Larry's labs and they
were selling cute puppies they had a
picture of a map where her kennel was
located they were accepting payment
through venmo or zel or some other
online source and they sent the puppy
purchaser to her kennel to pick up the
puppy and of course she was not Larry's
lab uh local police were notified Animal
Control is investigating her this went
on for about a year and a half despite
trying to assist her with making a
report on you know to the Department of
Justice around this fraud and um what I
learned is that a lot of these scammers
are foreign scammers so even if you end
up successfully getting a puppy that
maybe is sick um many people are getting
scammed and their money just being taken
and so I hope you will read that article
um the last thing I wanted to say is the
question came up about whether or not or
you heard a lot that these laws have
been passed in other states with and
everything's going well there um when
California implemented the law back in
2019 at that juncture in addition to
online scams and I didn't bring them
with me but I have articles from from
that time period of when it was
happening U there also was a puppy
laundering scheme the attorney general
for Iowa filed a lawsuit where there are
Bad actors out there as I'm describing
to you and they had set up a 501c3
called themselves a rescue
organization accepted donations as
though they were a charitable
organization purchased puppies at
auction and then turned around and was
selling them um online as rescues to
folks in California uh I also am aware
that there has been heavy litigation for
instance in the state of Maryland in
trying to implement the law that they
passed there it's been going on for
years um so those are some serious
concerns that the American Kennel Club
has um our recommendation is that uh New
Hampshire focus on enforcing your
current law you have a framework in
place to ensure that consumers have some
protections um to also do the education
so that consumers know where exactly um
they can go and see what they're
purchasing in person they can ask for
the V V aran's name who was responsible
for the health of that animal um and get
a copy of the health certificate um I
think you know I'm not dismissing that
there may be unfortunately uh
substandard careing conditions in other
states um New Hampshire has done a lot
of work to ensure that all animals
deserve Humane care and conditions um
and I think it is incumbent on the other
states to take action to ensure that any
substandard conditions there along with
the USDA the federal government to
ensure that those animals are cared in a
Humane in a humane way thank you thank
you representative
Murray thank you madam chair um thank
you for taking my question I briefly uh
hopped on to the Better Business
bureau's website while you were chatting
just and I was trying to figure out if
the this Matrix that you're showing here
is Germain to New Hampshire or if that's
um across the United States because
there is a way to filter and I wasn't
able to get it to work in any capacity
there is a way to filter you can even
track I think by even town for instance
which I haven't done in quite a while
but I think this is a a global article
from Better Business Bureau and I just
was wanting to share with you all how
when people were not able to go in
person to purchase a pet the increase in
the online scams um had gone up so
that's why I pulled this particular one
but you can go on um Better Business
Bureau they do have that track and you
can search by year and location it's a
it's a valuable
tool anyone else have a question uh
representative kulon thank you madam
chair and thanks for taking my question
um could you speak maybe a little bit to
the difficulty of actually buying
specific breeds of uh dogs in New
Hampshire I know I've been on the weight
list for two years for a livestock
Guardian dog actually so I've had for
people looking for a specific type of
working dog New Hampshire is actually a
challenging place to buy a dog could you
speak to that a little bit yeah I'm
happy to do that um AKC does a lot of
Education around um breeding healthy
happy litters of dogs uh we'd love to
see more people get involved in the in
this particular passion and and hobby
um
unfortunately there has been
longstanding culture of adopt don't shop
and that I think has had an impact on um
the number of individuals who are worth
to put in the Blood Sweat and Tears and
what it takes to actually produce a
healthy happy litter of puppies um here
in New England we only have one
veterinary school over at tus veterinary
school and I'm proud to share with you
that we had approached the dean to say
we were even having difficulty accessing
um K9 reproductive veterinarians in the
area uh to work with breeders and we've
uh established a program of an elective
where the veterinary students are
spending a semester with our AKC breeder
mentors on how to produce a healthy
litter of pups again to try and do that
education and engage people in what it
takes to produce a healthy uh purebred
dog that's bed breed for a particular
purpose um so thanks for the question um
yes there's a there is a shortage it's
not a matter of just saying well if you
shut down the pet stores they'll be a
bigger market for breeders um and
they'll make up the difference that's
that's I don't think that's an accurate
reflection of what the consequence of
this bill would
be any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you Miss oer
for thank you coming to testify today
and now I'd like to we've got three
cards left
left um like to get through um Katherine
Davis
verie five minutes please less than that
if you can I said five to seven just in
case but you might want to try a pet
store no I'm
joking all right uh dear Madam chair uh
Judy Aaron and uh Vice chair Jim kraton
and committee members my name is
Katherine Davis VY I retired last year
of owning a pet care business on the
seat Coast of New Hampshire for almost
20 years during my years living in Strat
of New Hampshire working for clients
taking care of their puppies I started
to notice sick puppies coming from a
store in Portsmith New Hampshire I
started to investigate why this was
happening I accumulated at the time by
the right to no law V certificates
mostly from Missouri to find out where
these pups were coming from and found a
world that I kind of knew but wasn't
sure of educating myself and working
with Animal Control Officers and police
officers in Maine and New Hampshire I
started started my journey to become an
activist not an extremist or paid
lobbyist to put a stop to the train of
mil pups coming trucked into New
Hamshire and Maine I started my by
educating the public one person at a
time by protesting store by store
starting in
2017 I was there for the main Bill LD
1311 Second Time Around in
2019 that it was eventually passed that
year with a bill passing in Maine I
connected with the director of New
Hampshire Maine Society Julia Julia cely
at the time and put the bill out for
someone in the house to sponsor 2020
State Rep Catherine the late uh State
Rep Katherine Rogers of conquered we
lost a beautiful person to cancer
sponsored the bill and we had our first
HB 1388 I see some familiar uh faces in
this room sadly Katherine Rogers passed
last year from cancer we lost a valuable
member of the house we are today here
for HB 1680 onate
uh with a few tweaks in it hopefully to
get it to pass um I hope you work with
us and let the representatives by the
people of New Hampshire the right to
vote on this bill it is our right to be
heard throughout the House of
Representatives currently while waiting
for the bill to bring this bill to
Hampshire towns have been doing their
own grassroot Banning of retail uh store
sales of puppies and kittens in the
state and Kurt arberg has the director
of New Hampshire has a total of this
record what I know is every town so far
that has put the Warren article
resolution on their B it
passes people don't want these stores in
their town or city what I know for the
past eight years from my experience
firsthand fact puppy sold at any pet
store is a m dog just because they are
registered by the AKC does not guarantee
they from a responsible breeder as it
would never ever sell to a retail store
I'm confused as the AKC lobbies for
retail sales in Pet Shops yet on AKC
Marketplace website I don't see them
advertis iing the stor is in any state
instead they advertise responsible
breeders I have no problem with
responsible breeders we we need great
breeders on the website I connected with
a breeder from Manchester New Hampshire
and asked if she sold her pups to the
Puppy Palace in Manchester she told me
she is a merit breeder and she would be
happy to speak to me about her breed but
stay away from the store regarding mpups
a pet scam we're talking we just were
talking about online this is that's a
different Bill to be talked about that's
not what we're talking about here fact
is puppies in Pet Shops are are not
always a careful thought it is an
emotional buy and the pet store knows
this and they have the financing for
them to keep their product moving as a
pet care person I have adopted two dogs
from clients that were emotional buys
and they had health issues their entire
life fact puppy mills operate for a
profit with no concern about the health
and treatment of the dogs in their care
the female breeding dog suffers the most
as they spend their entire life in a
small cage approved by the USDA and are
bred every heat cycle until they can't
produce props I would like to suggest
you watch a 2015 documentary called Dog
by dog producer Christopher Grimes an
examination of the profitable puppy mill
industry warning it is a real and harsh
reality you will really need to see it
if you're going to vote on this bill it
is free right now on YouTube because I
know they don't pay you enough but it'll
go back on Netflix soon fact testimonial
standing from my last packet which I had
that I handed out to everybody four
years ago it had everything in it I'm
not sending I'm not mailing uh sending
out packets this time uh but it has Doc
it documented veterinarian practicing in
the Sea Coast Mike schaer he gives
testimony on all the health issues for
the Pet Shop do
puppies um patterns of illnesses from
the Portsmith store they finally closed
they were here the last time they
finally Clos so that was one good thing
that happened behavioral issues from a
renowned dog trainer on the SE Coast
dogs mind Terrence Kirby I have any of
this information if you need it from me
I'll be happy to email it to you
firsthand with mil pups and they' caged
and isolated during critical soci
socialization periods demonstrates
higher instances of shyness fear-based
aggression and difficulty in house uh
breaking fact we are there are too many
breeders for the USDA to inspect each
facility the Purdue University the
canine certificate That's A New Concept
States in on their website there is no
standard definition of puppy mill exists
we Define puppy mills as a dog breeding
facility where profit is clearly given
priority over the well-being of the dogs
they are given the certificate by an
independently audited program doesn't
make sense to me as responsible breeders
don't sell to pet stores I have
testimony from well-known breeder Diane
of peace and love have in my files that
states the fact and milp breeders don't
care where they send their puppies and
they're out for the money what I know is
I don't want the state of New Hampshire
to become a Dumping Ground a Dumping
Ground a retail store is selling mil
pups because every state around them is
Banning that I told Governor sununu when
I saw him in at a signing in Salem New
Hampshire uh a year ago remember this
face remember my face I'm not giving up
I'm not a pretty snowflake that melts
I'm the Stick of gum under the desk that
you peel off but there's still a little
left because I have 20 years left in me
to fight this
battle I I want him to sign the bill I
know he's leaving in
2024 I'm not going anywhere I am not
profiting or being paid when I sit
before you I am Grassroots and want
better treatment for these
animals I can tell you now if you have
seen a puppy mill you would not be
against this bill it's working in the
state of Maine
it's
working and it can work here too thanks
that's it any questions from the
committee thank you thank you like to
call Angela
Ferrari good afternoon good afternoon I
have some print outs for
you
we we'll pass it to the clerk yep thank
you for bringing that
yep uh hello Angela Ferrari I am here on
behalf of dog owners of the granite
state for those of you who don't know
who we are um we
are our membership includes a vibrant
and active community of specialty breed
clubs all breed penel clubs dog and cat
breeders veterinarians mushers hunters
and livestock Guardian uh dog owners we
have been around since 1991 focusing on
pet
ownership we do oppose hb680
um before I get into changing the topic
up a little bit from what we've been
hearing I just did want to mention that
as part of my research for this bill I
did speak with various New Hampshire
veterinarians and there was more concern
with the health of rescue dogs in
comparison to those seen from pet stores
uh animals delivered to pet stores in
New Hampshire are already highly
regulated so any that are being imported
into the state that includes uh in the
state of their birth they're receiving a
health certificate in the state of their
distributor if they aren't coming here
directly from the straight of their
state of their birth by the federal
government if they're USDA licensed and
by New Hampshire when animals enter the
state um and we have animal cruelty or
animal cruelty is a criminal offense
everywhere so we have do have rules on
the books um if anything wasn't to be
following those outlined for health
certificates if there is sick puppies
being sold it is imperative that the
Vets providing the health certificates
are questioned and held accountable
under 437 col 8 the vet signing a health
certificate is the one responsible for
stores or breeders selling Sick Puppies
or cats um so we need to go back to the
basics and understand how these Health
certificates are being given for sick
animals we have quarantine requirements
of 48 hours for animals that are coming
into the state that is to make sure that
they do have a period of incubation
should they be coming with any diseases
while they're being transported to our
state after that period they would be
seen by a New Hampshire veterinarian who
would be Pro providing the health
certificate um representing the health
of that puppy Okay moving on additional
uh concerns that we have that we're
opposing this bill for are conflicts
with the New Hampshire antitrust law and
you'll see uh highlighted in yellow the
facts regarding the antitrust law it's
code section 356 colon1 under
prohibitive acts and it outlines that
every contract combination or conspiracy
and Restraint of
trade and this um is for the purpose of
fixing controlling maintaining limiting
or discontinuing the production
manufacturer mining sale or distribution
of any commodity or service so by this
bill coming in and telling a business
what they can or cannot sell we are
concerned about how that affects the New
Hampshire antitrust law we feel that
this is a restrictive business model or
restricts business models I should say
um it forces pet stores into a
restrictive business model we also feel
that there is potential taking without
just compens
compensation and when you look at the
section that talks
about um businesses not being able to
sell their business if someone's going
into business it is to try and build
something and you don't want it to die
when you die so you do want to be able
to sell your business and you've
established something that is worth
money um is it just selling cats or dogs
it's likely all of the accessories
there's so much more beyond the section
of the store that is including the sale
of cats and dogs but you want to be able
to sell that business get a return on
your investment um so without the
ability to do that except for within
family um that doesn't seem like a very
Pro bus type of restriction to have in
the law also um not being able to
relocate your business is quite an odd
one that's in here um so you aren't
allowed to transfer from one store to
another or location um if this bill was
to impact everyone that it could impact
it wouldn't just be pet stores but
somebody may not be able to sell their
home um because it had a kennel on it
for somebody else who was going to take
it over as a kennel property where they
may be selling puppies or kittens for
example uh in addition to just being
able to relocate your business to get
upgrades so we always talk about how we
want all of these breeders pet stores
you know anybody that has animals for
sale to have improved environments for
the animals that may require relocating
to a different facility where you can
have bigger enclosures for the animals
or you have better duct work for air
ventilation um things like that or you
may be able to upgrade the quantity of
washers and dryers that you have to keep
everything nice and clean so you would
actually be restricting them from being
able to make those type of
improvements um obviously we've heard a
lot about the increased Reliance on
rescues and outof state Brokers so we do
feel that this bill actually promotes
shelters and rescues purchas from
commercial entities which contradicts
its intent you've heard talk about um
rescues getting dogs from auctions um
the commercial kennels that we're
talking about across the country they
may relinquish animals to rescues um for
resale when they're no longer using them
for breeding or if they've been unable
to sell them so I just want everyone to
know that rest reses are obtaining
animals from the exact places that this
bill is intended to supposedly stop
um we also feel that it gives rescues a
monopoly by limiting local options for
obtaining pets and forcing individuals
to resort to sight unseen online Brokers
traveling out of state or working with
breeders who haven't necessarily met the
pet vendor threshold this raises
concerned about increased demand for
rescues potential scams and disease
risks um we feel this bill is only going
to increase imported rescue animals and
um disease such as the canine respitory
illness that we've seen running rampant
in New Hampshire we've also seen parvo
and distemper cases increasing parasite
cases
increasing um including parasitic
immunity to standard treatments and
these are not due due to purebred dog
and cat sales but we feel that they're
due to rescues who ignore the laws for
importation into New
Hampshire um see I think I had one more
piece here oh I did want to mention
consumer choice is being taken away and
accessibility for the consumers who may
purchase a dog or cat from a pet store
and it's important for those who don't
have access to breeders or rescue um we
heard about what the weight list can be
like for getting some getting a puppy
from a breeder myself I breed doberman's
um my weight list is two years out so
that matches you know what we've heard
earlier and people don't want to wait
that long I love my people who are
willing to take the time and wait and
have that rapport with me over that
waiting period um but not everybody is
going to be able to do that and that
isn't necessarily a bad thing for them
because sometimes the time is now it's
maybe summer vacation you have three
months with your kids and the dog to be
at home get it potty trained before
everyone goes back to school you go back
to work whatever it might be so there
are reasons when waiting isn't always
going to be the best option for
everybody we also can't expect that
everyone is going to be satisfied or
with a rescue dog or have that dog be
appropriate for them you are limited on
Choice size temperament you don't know
the health or background of that dog
similarly to a puppy that might be
coming into a pet store it may only have
been in New Hampshire for two-day
quarantine period sitting in the rescue
for a week and off it is into its new
home so it is really no different in
that aspect um but we are bringing in
potential disease every time we import a
dog and with the older dogs we really
aren't sure about temperament and I
think we hear a lot about that um so we
also feel this bill is unnecessary as
there are a low number of pet stores
selling dogs and cats in New Hampshire I
think we heard the number is five maybe
there's a six one we're not sure and we
have uh concerns about you know the
rescue dogs compared to those from the
pet stores after speaking with the local
veterinarians and the existing
regulations and criminal offenses
related to animal cruelty as well as
consumer protections should be deemed
sufficient
so we would urge you to vote this bill
itl if further discussions do happen
about Alternatives with this bill here I
would greatly appreciate uh opening the
floor with you all to discuss those
potentials I'll take any questions thank
you representative
Bixby based on your testimony please put
on your mic Bas on your testimony and
the testimony of the commissioner there
are um potential issues with the
sourcing of rescue dogs based on other
testimony it sounds like there are
potential issues and and and health
issues with dogs at pet stores uh do you
think it might make sense to uh send
this bill to interim study in order to
get a broader sort of um uh solution
that uh the commissioner was suggesting
in terms of finding characteristics of
dogs coming into the state that would
allow us to limit the ones that are not
um that shouldn't be coming into the
state uh thank you for the question um I
do think that that is a a consideration
I feel like we're starting with
something that just goes so far beyond
where we even want to be um that you
know it's kind of a muddy place to start
but if it's just to kind look at what
some options could be we might be able
to get behind behind that representative
na thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question are you could you
just clarify for me your organization is
it dog owners does it also include
breeders and Retail yep um it's dog
owners of the Granite State you can find
us at NH dogs.org and we include
specialty breed clubs that are in New
Hampshire you know we're only New
Hampshire based um so our kennel clubs
are New Hampshire our dog and cat
breeders are New Hampshire uh
veterinarians in our group are from New
Hampshire we also have mushers hunters
and livestock Guardian dog owners um and
then just general you know regular dog
owners you know they've been joining
us yep any other questions from members
of the
committee seeing none thank you very
much and we appreciate you sticking
around so long thank you all uh our my
last pin card is from Taylor
lelli
everyone thank you for the opportunity
to speak with you all today on House
Bill 1680 my name is Taylor lelli and I
am here on behalf of the pet advocacy
Network you all should have testimony
from me that was handed out
previously um the pet advocacy Network
is the largest pet trade Association in
the nation we represent members
throughout the country but also in New
Hampshire so I am here on behalf of the
pet advocacy Network to ask you to vote
no to House Bill
1680 we know that pet stores are the
most highly regulated and transparent
source for consumers to obtain an animal
in New Hampshire and we have seen these
pet sale bands plague the nation
specifically in places like California
that's been brought up today where
veterinarians reported a large increase
in sick animals two years after that pet
sale ban was enacted and puppy scams
increased by
350% according to the Better Business
Bureau um I know we talked a lot about
people going online as a source to get
their dogs I do want to correct and make
known that the USDA regulating online
pet sales is minimal at best um it's
mostly complaint-based when they're
searching for unlicensed vendors so
that's not something that they have a
division that they're looking actively
for at this
time um
additionally I think that it is
important to note that there are Bad
actors in The Pet Care Community we are
not here to dispute that we just believe
there's a lot better ways to address
that than pet sale bans if that's
something that you choose to do again
that could be with things like sourcing
restrictions or Banning roadside sale of
puppies but I do think it's also
important to note that pet stores are
already regulated in New Hampshire
you've heard numerous ways of how um I
will reiterate again that they are
required to provide a 14-day warranty
provide that Veterinary Care certificate
they can't sell puppies and kittens
under 8 weeks of age
they must be licensed clean and sanitary
facilities we do at the pet advocacy
Network think it's very important to
protect pet Choice there are families
that cannot get a dog from a shelter
because they may have something like
allergies and they or they just want to
know their animals full medical history
which is something that a pet store can
offer
them um we know that also I had provided
in my testimony the numerous ways that
the pet industry helps boost and protect
the economy in New Hampshire so to enact
this ban would be an attack on the small
businesses that do this now we do
welcome collaboration with you all if
you choose to consider other legislation
we'd love to be a part of those
conversations we've done so in other
states um but we do think that we would
love if you voted no to House Bill 1680
because this is not going to result in
the elimination of pppy Mills thank you
and I'll take any
questions representative NAB thank you
madam share um so we heard earlier that
it is pretty easy to look online and see
where a pet store is getting its pets
from and it sounds like you would
support legislation that would ensure
that where the dogs are coming from into
a pet store is a licensed reader yes
USDA license and there are states that
do that already um Arizona has some some
great examples again if that's something
you guys choose to pursue we're happy to
work with you on that um there is an
appropriate way to go about that but we
just want to make sure that everyone's a
part of that conversation all right
thank you
yeah any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony this
afternoon and uh we have no other pink
sheets so um I'd like to have the she
brought thank
you I know um the online portal shows
that there were
82 people uh writing in support of this
legislation and 14
opposed and on our blue signup sheet we
had one two three four five people in
support and two two people
opposed with that I'm going to close uh
the hearing for hb680
and I thank you all very much for your
time it's been a really long
day
um plans for our committee uh we plan to
meet again Monday the 22nd of
January and um we W I'm planning on um
having committee work session on um two
three four five six
bills uh so I guess we'll we'll have
some discussion in on the 22nd in the
afternoon
22nd 22nd in the afternoon yes okay so I
thought that we were we are also doing a
work session on Wednesday the 31st okay
yeah yes we will be hearing bills in the
morning and then one bill in the
afternoon and then um the other half of
the afternoon we're going to do uh
discussion on some
bills uh 1685 redefining Homestead Foods
as Artisan
Foods
okay all right thank you all set and
again my apologies for today going so
long and um I hope that you all drive
safe and be
careful